is nikki our most guested guest
i believe she is wow
i'm really flattered that means a lot
pretty wild i when i ask you if i can do
the podcast i'm always
it's always with a million like no press
it's my dream i but i really just it's a
great way to hang out with you i know
it's like with lights and cameras and
microphones but i feel like we quickly
let go of that i don't know it's just a
great way i just things come out of me i
learned stuff i was like meditating on
the way here
and i was like i feel like i'm gonna
like make out with whitney today like
because i i know that's like the weird i
don't even know why i just said that but
like that is how you make me you're so
beautiful to look at you make me feel so
like seen and warm and like i was just
like i need like a whitney hug i just
felt um good coming into here today you
are so nice to me and i love you and i
feel like true friends which you know
the the older i get are they maybe the
more like girl friendships i sort of
get better at and get you know realize
never worked and it wasn't my fault uh
it was never a match or going through
friend breakups is always weird but i do
feel like in romantic relationships i've
always liked trauma bonding is bad the
faster something is the more unhealthy
it is but like sometimes i feel like if
you really know yourself as a person as
you get older like you can make old new
friends fast yes and i would have
thought that was toxic like two years
ago really i would have thought my
feelings towards you were toxic but now
i think they're actually like healthy
and i know who i am and we actually have
really good boundaries really good but
when but i feel like when we connect we
connect hard but i never am like is she
mad at me i'm so glad why isn't if you
don't text me back maybe this is
maybe you're probably going like cabbage
i don't i'm trying to send you a message
you didn't get it i'm like i don't take
it personally yeah i know it's because
you don't want to shit no i just feel
like you're busy and you have stuff
going on okay i need to be a little bit
more obvious
no but that's so that makes me feel good
i love that because i i feel that with
you like when there's been time it's
it's so lovely with you because because
we have such a uh we're so open about
having boundaries and you're so full of
like that kind of
messaging there have been times where
i'm like whitney i need to to go and i'm
i'm gonna like do exactly what i know
that you'll respect me to do and like
it's so hard for me to be like d like
when you're when you're really
connecting or i have to go or i want to
give you what i think you need even
though you don't need it like you're at
the common store last night and i was
like i could have crossed paths with you
and then i was just like i just got it
because i know i want to just talk to
you and
that's really where i know that about
myself too i will i will drain my own
energy on somebody if i see them and
i'll avoid them not to be like it's not
that i don't want to talk to you i just
like want to talk to you so bad and i
know this will go till two in the
morning and i'll abuse myself with you
yes yes um i know what you guys are
thinking uh where did whitney get her
cute sweatshirt this i got on some very
sketchy website and i don't encourage it
um this was a mistake the only
i mean you guys see the stuff that comes
in the mail
the only thing that has not been a
mistake that i've put on my body in the
last
couple years frankly is this workout
stuff fiori
yeah when i'm not wearing my hydrated
masturbate sweatshirt i'm in a viewery
sweatsuit emily is wearing a shirt that
says hydrate and masturbate um it was a
gift
and and uh grace is wearing a jacket
that says donna she stole it from
someone um and so we
we needed this we needed an upgrade yeah
in our looks they are designed to look
great in everyday life aka outside the
gym and they're perfect for any workout
activity so i here's the thing about me
is that i you never know when i'm going
to work out oh that is so very true
it is it could come at any moment
and i'm always kind of working out yep
yep in many ways fiori is an investment
in your happiness so for our listeners
they are offering 20 off your first
purchase
because like yeast infections i just
feel like are out
personally a lot of workout clothes
you're not getting the
the amount of oxygen you need to your
crevices yeah and i've had it get
yourself some of the most comfortable
and versatile clothing on the planet
versatile
versatile
it could be potato potato depends on how
fast tomato tomato or crown crayon
this is a this is you already done a
work fiori.com whitney that's v u o r i
dot com slash whitney you owe it to your
crevices yep and not only will you
receive 20 off your first purchase but
enjoy free shipping on any us orders
over 75 and free returns don't make
people look at your ratty workout
clothes either go to
whitney and discover the versatility of
yori clothing
okay so folks this weekend is a big big
weekend jesus is coming back i
jesus is returning um on sunday um and
also
my career is gonna end because we are
doing a live good for you podcast
no cuts no emily going we can't say that
we need to cut that i'm just gonna say
it and what are you gonna do
nothing the live show is going to be
it's um we're going to have like bowls
of drugs and random things we have
friars we're also playing strip truth or
dare and then burke chrysler is joining
as well um and like my by the way
shrinking it by the way just can we stop
for a second who wrote this copy was it
yo
no it's me really we're gonna play
drinking game strip truth or date
okay first of all
it's a little bit of a that
is funny
slip instead of truth or dare
tell me the truth or you have to go on a
date with me and it's going to be i mean
it's
it's going to be
we're going to do some damage i i go
hard at truth or dare i don't play
around
what you guys saw in the jen kramer
episode where i got blackout drunk by
accident
that was after like two weeks of editing
it was that insane you have to get your
tickets at momenthouse.com good for you
april 17th 6 p.m pacific standard time
easter will be over you'll found your
eggs i love you guys and back to the
guest
for sure cool can i just jump around
because i've not talked about this at
all publicly about the will smith thing
have you talked about it so much already
just a little bit but uh not since i've
actually had time to like think on it
whatever you haven't talked about it on
your bike no i just haven't i haven't
had a comedian on like we haven't
recorded saying yes and it was like i
never also want to be one of those
people that's like let me give you my
take to try to like
get some clout from like something awful
that happened or like i don't need this
no one is like standing by like i have
to like watch that with myself i'm like
everybody's like getting so many likes
on instagram giving their take i guess i
need to get mine and i'm like no i'll
just like oh i was going crazy on
twitter that night but then the next
days uh gary alabate from the cern show
called like i woke up in the like at six
o'clock in the morning to go pee and i
saw my phone and it was like gary being
like hey could you call the show like
yes i mean i was like i just was like
why did i see you ever get asked to do
something and you go i gotta do it
because it's such like a great platform
like i can't say no to star i just don't
say no to stern so like it would have
been nice to just miss this because i
don't know what i think yet and i'm i
have a feeling i'm going to put my foot
in my mouth so yeah i did say stuff on
there that i i'm glad that i stand by
but i i have more opinions on it now
yeah i guess to me i have like a couple
like i just like i'm all obviously like
what he did was disgusting you know as a
comedian i'm always going to like play
here the tweet i deleted which i cannot
believe twitter got me to delete a tweet
but i did it it was maybe it just it was
about um
like of course the guy
that made a documentary called good hair
is gonna go after the bald chick
it was like something in that was very
ironic i know well no it's like what did
you think of court you know it was like
something in that it was just like on so
many levels like like the more i think
about it the more fucked up it gets
where were you when it happened were you
so funny i was not watching no it's like
the new yeah where are we where were you
which is so annoying that's a chris rock
joke where were you oh my god that's so
true last night i was uh at the store
and mark maron was like i was watching
it live and i was like a lot like some
people saw it live and i didn't see it
live but i think
if i thought live i would have thought
it was fake there's no way i would have
been
i don't know what i would have thought i
think the muting where it went muted
that would have led me to believe that
it was not fake i can't play it back
because chris like seeing him not be
scared at all because the likelihood of
that happening was so
impossible that chris is like what are
you doing man like
hey like when you think about like the
number of steps he there are a number of
steps he had to change his mind to like
back out of it to turn it into like a
noogie or like uh i came up here angry
about like and i'll do a fake slap or
like
you you know what i mean it could have
like a lot of bad decisions yeah the
person that just was in 20 minutes gonna
win the best actor award couldn't act
like he had his shit together in that
moment like
so i don't think we can even
does anyone remember that he won best
actor i mean like that was completely
eclipsed by this like it it was an app
it wasn't after here's here's the thing
that's a huge deal i will have to win
the best actor wild right that already
is like so that would have been so
exciting without all this like that
would have been such a cool moment will
smith r will smith yeah like
yeah you know
black fresh prince uh he's academy award
winning that is an alternative universe
that is string theory like an
alternative reality no my mind didn't
even realize what we lost yes like that
moment yeah that's crazy will smith
summer summer summer
like where were you so tell me
how it went down i was uh well i am in a
c okay so i identify as an addict we all
know that i am addicted to ozark in a
way that is like i'm driving i'm
watching it driving like are you
re-watching it or not
here's the thing so the same way if i
were to uh be a drug user i know that
when i do drink sometimes i'll go i'm
gonna skip dinner so it hits harder like
i don't you wanna feel it oh i'll feel
it harder yeah you know what i'm saying
so
ozark i was like i'm gonna wait like the
only thing
better than ozark is ozark
back-to-back
and like not having to wait between and
he's having to hear people talk about it
and like sort of like i just i watched
mad men
in december what it was if you thought
it was good 10 years ago now oh my god
it's so much better wait so i like to
sit on shows you were watching ozarks
while going driving through an
intersection
i'm driving oh yeah so i was addicted to
ozark and then my friend nick comes in
and is like dude and i was like what
he's like you gotta watch the oscars and
i'm like when has anyone said that in
the last 10 years and he's like i'm
telling you trust me this is wild and
it
he was like careful to show it to me i
was like did someone fall like why did
someone say the n word like you know and
he showed it to me
and i just had this pit in my stomach
and i've had to pit my stomach since
yeah
it's
i i've had a lot of obviously we've had
how long has it been um a week a week
and a half yeah i feel what i've
determined and this is just obviously
speculation is that
i i will obviously he is someone with
that deeply in pain hurt people hurt
people we all know that but
i think that what was ev what was what
was on the other side of that look he
got from his wife was more threatening
to his
you know
happiness
than what he was going to do up there to
to chris rock so he had just two
decisions you know a decision deal with
this
which could be who knows what that could
be a month of of of getting iced out at
home because here's what i'm thinking
about going off and doing things to hurt
me like i'm fascinated by like
because it seems like there was a
history there you know like with like
chris had made jokes about him before
like just as comedians like whose are
will smith in ten years who's gonna be
like enough nikki
like that's the last straw like i think
he was
really his anger towards
i think mine is just projected up there
what i feel like one day chris angel is
just gonna come up to me and be like
fuck you and i'm like what well you're
not gonna see it coming no just i didn't
realize how many times i've made fun of
illusionist you know
i'm also not gonna see him coming
because i could probably never get him
hard or to come
that's a different story
i did see a poster of him in vegas and i
go do you are you doing is this
are you serious
with this
do you want people to take you seriously
those are the people that lose their
mind dude i'm telling you he's like
putting on that urban decay eyeliner
every morning my god
means it so my thing is like i feel like
there's when we make people punch lines
like it's just we're putting a target on
our back for those people to snap
and it's a good idea what do they need
to stop making fun of i feel like i
don't
i don't know i feel like honestly my
myself like i need to like stop being
mean because i'm going to get myself and
i don't know like because i feel like
that's the person that i always like but
like sometimes i really feel like i like
bully myself like try to come up with
the meanest thing that i would like
cyber bully with like i'll or i'll
imagine people are gonna say that i
don't read comments anymore but what i
imagine
that i would write if i was a sicko and
wanted to like get like that's what i'll
come up with like what what could they
say about me and then all of a sudden
i'm like formulating these well isn't
that kind of part of what i've spelled
like all caps locked i think being
comedian it's like i'm gonna hurt myself
before you can hurt me yeah yeah i'm
gonna say the worst thing about it so
that you can't i mean it's like the
quote i love of uh being a comedian is
uh we did it to control how we're
embarrassed like i'm just going to
embarrass myself and control the
situation but i mean like punchline i
just feel like we watched a
man break
yes like break and it was like you know
making fun of people it is like all fun
and games until society is on the like
hinge of collapse and people just start
like breaking down
and i just think it's so funny to think
about like
all those people out there that are
walking punch lines that we're just like
oh how do we think this is gonna end
it is do you think that the seating had
anything to do with this like you know
how they used to be seated rose like if
he had to go like excuse me
like roberto benini over people
would have been like a straight shot i
mean it was incredibly direct but
god i just like to walk and i haven't
processed this with anyone yet right
because i'm sure i'm gonna like you know
it's just so incendiary i mean we did on
the good for you instagram page uh we
did a photo of jada pickett's myth and
it was like get your wife's name out of
your mouth and then it said jada's mouth
and it was like a million hot dogs
i saw that yeah i feel like we talk i
feel bad talking about will smith chris
rock stuff now i think we have empathy
for both sides we we admit that we don't
know the full story it made us feel sad
we're we're not acting like victims
we're not acting like this is
like someone last night referred to us
like the 9 11 of comedy and i was just
like that's easy
like comedians we need to be a little
less self-important about like of course
but but
it was just a weird sad moment it felt
like a fever dream i like to go like
what are the takeaways just really quick
i think something that i hear a lot from
people which by the way my number one
pet peeve right now is when you say
something and on twitter everyone will
be like not the take you're like i don't
know
when i go to your bio on twitter it's
like proud dad
dad of lola and olivia like it's such a
shameful phrase that it takes me really
just one why do i then go oh my god
you're right it's not i'm like what
i didn't sign up to have the takes yeah
i signed up to make the jokes yes and i
also
i get it wrong okay it's not the take
well okay don't this little like passive
aggressive not the take like there's a
better way to tell me can you imagine if
comedians always were right like what is
fun in that you know what i mean like it
just is like i'm just here to be the
silly goose yes and so not the take
drives me not so i'm trying to not say
but do you think that we're going to get
more people
trying to punch us on state and like
assault us do you think that's going to
be a thing because i i do i think in
general what i'm going to say is i think
that it's not just a comedian thing i
think it's everybody's at their breaking
point and i think we're not designed for
this kind of fame we're not designed for
this kind of uh social media feedback
will smith when he signed up to be
famous the first 30 years he was famous
there was no one being like hey so
what's up with your wife cheating on you
like you could do that stuff in private
yeah the idea of being that famous with
that many people knowing your business
and feeling the kind of mass
emasculation on that scale i don't think
human beings are designed for it and i
think we watched will smith we watch i
think we will look back in 50 years and
go remember when we let famous people
read their
social media
remember when we let famous we lost so
many good ones because we let them read
we just let remember when we let
celebrities smoking on planes yeah
you know it's like we just see like
remember when like someone put out a
movie and someone would go like you
didn't cast an autistic person to play
an autistic person cancel like it's just
like
we just let someone read all that
feedback like i think that like you know
famous people it's hard because they
have so much money it's hard to have any
compassion for that and they asked for
it you know what you were getting in and
you know what i mean
hasn't anyone ever gone into something
and thought it was going to be in some
way and yeah and
just a regular person that says that of
goes you're famous and this is what you
wanted you knew what you were getting
you're you're putting yourself out there
we get to judge you
i didn't know it was going to be like
but you're just going to say i need a
job
so will smith has done these all these
amazing movies whatever like if he has a
dud if he has a clunker of a movie we're
like clunker bomb in what job at h r
block when a job goes wrong
there are people like you fucking bomb
that
like you would go to human resources
like this is the only job where it's
like people
can talk to you like that it's so funny
david spade was talking about his
remember his hollywood minute was on snl
that
he used to that was the only he was
talking about he was like there was no
making fun of celebrities back then ever
it was just like only glorifying them
that is it there was no he was the only
one that was the first time
and now that is
most of the noise about celebrities
and these are also people it's hard to
feel sorry for celebrities i get it but
these are people that are like
emotionally stunted that basically when
i just want strangers to love me i want
to disappear into other identities we
didn't know people wouldn't strangers
this is a very psychologically fragile
person already okay already these are
like i mean i think a lot of like big
actors and people who got famous young
like you do kind of freeze at the age
you became famous i believe that and
then you're like you have to kind of be
a child in a lot of ways you know you
get things brought to you all the time
like just the idea of consequences just
go out the window i'm not having
sympathy for people that have been
enabled this long but it's just the idea
that we just like
let them
loose and like let them read their
comments you know i don't know i just i
don't think that human beings are
designed for fame if we're not schoolers
or like that's cyberbullying there's
also a lot of and everyone's famous in
their own way if you're in pensacola and
you have ten thousand followers you're
famous if you're the local weather girl
like fame doesn't have to mean 70
million people i mean there's a lot of
evidence the points are like we're not
designed for mirrors oh right there are
no mirrors in nature yes zero like we're
not designed to see ourselves until
movies there was that's what's so
captivating about movies is because
evel evolution i don't know the word for
it evolutionarily we have never been
able to be that close to a human's face
without them seeing us it is bizarre it
is insane there's never been a time
where you could stare at someone's face
that close and see that the only time
you don't know the only time you would
be that close to a human gavin debecker
talks about this is the only the reason
there's so many like dangerous
parasocial relationships now with
celebrities and people thinking they're
in relationships with them like you know
it's getting into it if you were
the only time you would ever get that
close to anyone is if you're about to
kiss them you know you see their laugh
lines you see their pores like it really
you know and so um i i do think we will
look back and go like okay
when a famous person will protect famous
people more i mean when you think about
the amount of people that have died
whether it's it's like amy winehouse and
heath ledger like when he said those
people are dead dude that's like i was
watching the whitney houston documentary
and i was like we are blood on all our
hands
because then it becomes a punchline like
every talk show host is like yeah
because she does crack and she's a
crackhead and she's at this it's like
you look back at the way we treated like
britney spears and these people and
you're like we almost lost her that was
real close you're like this is i know
they're rich but that is what we're all
telling ourselves to get away with like
really gross behavior towards
just as um
uh
you know guilty as that girl who like
you know texted the guy get back in the
car and kill yourself like that's what
adults cyberbullies other adults but
they get away with if you were a middle
schooler doing that you'd be kicked out
of school like some kids are protected
from cyber bullying but celebrity we're
all like i'm children stunted children
like to help people tell us people tell
me to kill myself all the time people
tell me like the worst things about they
you know that and i'm not but i asked
for it because i i'm a celebrity but i
think that we are a little bit at the
brink so like to answer your question
about the the our comedian's gonna get
hit more and all that kind of stuff like
who knows i do think everyone's on the
brink like we were just in dallas like a
fight just broke out in dallas like
really ended the show
[Music]
i think everyone's just at their last
fucking nerve yeah i think that after
the pandemic everyone's living through
their phone vicariously you have all the
control in the world you only get things
that are really opening up and people
can't handle no you only get marketed
things that you want to buy you only see
news that you want to see you only
follow people when you see something
that you don't want and then you go in
public and you can't control any of this
that's like my fear about all the
metaverse stuff and all this thing where
you get to control your world you live
on video games and then you go out of
the world and you can't control people's
behavior and you're like oh my god we're
so desensitized to anything
unpredictable happening
listen that is the take i like that like
i think we're just these feral animals
and like our nature is coming i mean
this guy basically was just like trying
to get out of the aisle and some he got
too close to this guy and he just
knocked him out i think we're all at
like peak
like and i think what we saw with was
like a confluence of a lot of that but i
do think it's like people are just going
to start breaking more and more yes just
losing their shit like this whole
illusion of like civilized society i
feel like it's just kind of starting to
fall apart yeah yeah yeah and this one
this was the first sign of it the slap
the oscars was like oh that was that was
it that's when things started to get
really weird which is also weird when
we're like okay we watch all these
celebrities die and overdose and kill
themselves and hang themselves and we're
like but that is the thing where we were
like
yeah this is wild because it's the
oscars that does not i mean maybe the
golden globes yeah
yeah razzies
but it was i also think that chris like
won't really talk about it that much
weirdly like everyone's gonna talk about
it i'm like it's not even no no if i'm
him i'm never like the idea that
the physical harm like all that the idea
that you like this is
like chris rock is such a great comedian
that i think he'll be able to like
you know
obfuscate this with great work after
this but the idea that it's like you
just
made my legacy about this i know that's
the shame it's like this is and here's
one thing i will say what i did i just
did something i just did like a
corporate every time i'm googled this
will come up
like you did that yes like you
embarrassed me did i and you took my
google searches forever for that is that
is his mark like that to me is just like
the most fucked up shit you can do
people um that are like well why did he
come after his wife and dad if you're
walking into a situation where you
understand that comedians are gonna be
making jokes and you're one of the most
famous people in the world in a
weird-ass relationship that everyone's
always made fun of chances are like you
might get made fun of yeah and i did
this corporate gig recently where i was
like doing this roast and paris hilton
was there and she texted me before and
she was like
can you not make fun like can i just see
like for her literally she goes like i
go let me send you the joke right now
it's like about her like it wasn't her
at her expense at all it was like you
know but i was like i am so fucking
proud of you that is so fucking punk
rock i sent her the joke she's like oh
my god thank you she was just like i
don't i know what i'm walking into i
know girl has been working on herself
that's like that's something that a
healthy person does i know who i am
that's what i need i know who you are i
know the situation but i can read
context clues and i'm just going to be
an adult and send you a message so it's
like if will smith knew he was walking
he could have been like hey chris
yeah could you be easy on us tonight
like you could it could have gotten to
the writers and it would have been a
note that everyone had to heed of like
don't go there just like hey i know the
situation
situations we know when things are off
limits and we have to abide by those and
we don't go actually i'm going to go
hard like we're not cruel it was just
like i just literally when that happened
when i was like oh maybe he got hit
sideways and did it and i was like no
like it is just
comedians never want to hurt anyone it's
just like the idea that people are like
being so hard on comedians now and we're
like remember like five years ago in the
stereotype is we were like mentally ill
and depressed and all suicidal and like
we're all crazy and fragile and now you
guys are just like hitting us
like we like people are ever like oh
whoa are you gonna roast me like i'm
scared of you i'm always like i co i you
have i'm the opposite of that that is
just me do like writing those are like
jokes are like math problems i'm not
like those aren't there's truth behind
them but yeah this i do not think of
that way and this joke about you has
nothing to do with it nothing to do it
was just a good question i know and i'm
not like that at all it just that is
roasted kind of and i'm sure you have it
too of giving me like this kind of
reputation that i cannot live up to of
being like a ball buster i'm gonna start
doing i think if the i i'm not sure if
the deals gonna happen or not but um i'm
gonna start doing on i remember over the
pandemic i remember being like i have
this weird superpower of writing rose
jokes that i can never use i feel like
anymore and it's just like sitting on
the bench here and uh and so i was like
god you know where you can do rose now
it's like only fans like i was like
there's videos of like dirty videos and
dirty photos i'm like what if there's a
place where it's like dirty jokes that
you can't tell anywhere else and so i
might start doing little roasts on only
that's so fun yeah because it's also you
can't
go through a paywall going to only fans
and then be like you're punching down
it's like you're here you yeah we're
down in the mud we're all in the fucking
mud you don't get to say that i'm like
you know any of this is problematic but
we know what this is i guess it's just
too serious to joke about or whatever
like i didn't realize you know oh really
yeah
well it's like if you criticize their
marriage you're coming after a black
woman if you criticize it it's just like
it's so incendiary and i think a lot of
people are just like white people
shouldn't insert themselves in this but
it's also like as comedians i feel like
it's you know we should be able to talk
about what happens when someone assaults
a comedian on stage yeah i mean there
there was a lot of that that night of
like
white people need to sit this one out
like i read that a lot and as soon as i
read that i go into like fuck like i
you're you're right like i just always
assume they're right because who am i to
say that they're not right like it's
kind of a
statement that you get and you go i
really don't have any but i also want to
go like hey scientology is a white
person problem
so i feel like
you need to set this one up scientology
i mean
did they come out and say they weren't
like i don't know the history there i
mean it's pretty it's no one will say it
because no one will say it but yes i'm
not worried the scientologist come
fucking at me dude i'll stick my robot
on you like you think you guys are
fucking crazy i'm not afraid of
scientology really at all i am you guys
are cool what do you what are you gonna
do
it's totally fine what are you gonna
fucking do dude the problem is here's
what i realized comedians are invincible
you can't humiliate me you can't
embarrass me what are you gonna fuck
that's a really good point what are you
gonna do to me grateful that's how they
well that's how scientology stays
powerful is that it has people's secrets
yeah and it bribes them and says well
i'm gonna tell everyone you're gay
you're gonna have to take money sue me i
guess you audit like they basically
stole from 12-step programs like you
reveal all your secrets and that's how
you're going to have grace and all this
kind of stuff but like
they're just like letting kids die of
seizures like i'm not
i don't fuck with you guys because we'll
tell people you're gay and then you
won't get in movies anymore but even
though everyone is the only way to get
into movies right now they're still
they're i think they keep them like
like they they keep it like the 80s in
there like where that would have been
ruining your all the guys that they have
that they're keeping these gay secrets
on are conditioned to think that will
ruin their careers even though it would
be great for
the men the three men i'm mainly talking
about like the ones we all know yeah
it's just so yeah i mean i don't know on
the other hand sometimes i'm like super
pro scientology because i'm like if
you're susceptible to this like please
be locked in a building because if you
weren't doing this i think people are so
susceptible to brainwashing and like
interesting it's just
i fee i agree with you of like okay bye
like yeah like get good if you think
this is a good idea maybe stay in there
because who knows what else you think is
a good idea yes yes but i also feel like
everyone thinks they're not susceptible
to brainwashing when we kind of already
are in certain ways in different ways
and like so many family members have
been lost to like fox news of people
that were like he used to be like saint
like that's a type of
brainwashing it's i mean we i had this
at neuroscientists on the podcast the
other day i actually thought of you
because he was like we're going to look
back in 50 years and you'll get canceled
if there's like a photo of you like
eating meat
or like yes stuff like that yeah like
what are the things we're doing now like
i feel like even just now talking about
like oh people's brains were just wired
that way we shamed people that wanted to
jerk off in public we were like ew like
the idea that we look we'll probably
look back at that one day the way that
we look at the way they like had
children working in factories we're like
oh my god we can't believe we ever
treated people like that it's well i'm
kind of like i don't shame people for
like i actually do think that no one
chooses we don't have free will i
100 think that and i know it because
i've read enough about it and it's a
freaky concept but
no you know because we're in a
simulation i don't know about that yet i
haven't been on rogan since he moved to
austin but i don't know
i what i do know is that when you know
the argument that i always like to to
talk about is when you know someone does
like a mass shooting or something and
they they kill them and they do an
autopsy on their brain and they're like
this guy was normal what happened they
they open him up and they go oh my god
he had a tumor that was pressing on his
amygdala this makes sense that's why
this guy did it but truthfully any time
anyone does anything it's because
something's going on in their brain yet
we excuse it when we can see it but most
of the time we cannot see it but no one
wants to be i'm not excusing this
behavior no one wants to be a pedophile
no one if you were given a choice and i
know that it you seem it
it there's a part of me that obviously
does not have sympathy for those people
because but there is a part of me
honestly that thinks i wish that they
had a place to go so they could go
listen i'm attracted to kids and i
haven't done anything about it please
help me because there's nowhere to go
and i'm gonna no of course not and it's
like you know i mean look you go and you
get changed people go oh you're
disgusting they take you to jail i mean
there's a place to go for them it's
called
you know
you guys
i i i don't know how many times i have
to say this
i'm getting sick of repeating myself
are you sure
i am not i if there's anything i hate
doing it's repeating myself
and i won't do it again okay and i am
sick of talking and saying this
because there's nothing i hate more
than talking
and giving my opinions and lecturing you
guys on how to make the same choices i
make
so
i've said it
for a year and a half now i've told you
i take ritual vitamins do you are you
deaf
are you just not listening
are you just trying to make a point
is this a prank are you mental i've said
this a thousand times
i've said it i'm not going to say it
again all right if you two want to say
it you can say it i'll say it because
i've only said it because boundaries are
for us rituals essential for women 18
plus multivitamin was formulated from
exhaustive research to help fill
nutrient gaps in the diets 18 ages 18
plus it is formulated with nutrients to
help support brain health bone health
blood health and provide antioxidant
support but rachel did not stop there
didn't agree no
they invested in gold standard
university-led clinical trials to prove
the impact of their essential for women
18 and up multivitamin which is also
just gorgeous and right now ritual is
offering my lip i'm thinking about it
offering my listeners
okay ten percent off your first response
visit ritual.com
and turn healthy habits into a ritual
that's 10 off at ritual.com
it would be so funny that the day you
tried to just like take over this whole
business you were like
i'm cutting bangs
like this
you do have the time is now you did
when a bitch just shows up with bangs
out of nowhere like something happens
now i know what you listeners are
thinking while you watch this christmas
this is grace's listeners are thinking
this is a well-organized well-fueled
organized machine which must have some
type of workflow
organization and it's true we use
monday.com
because it's an operating system and
platform where anyone can easily create
or customize work software because you
know what i i had a system that i
thought was working which was just
thumbs up a text
and i it just didn't stick for some
reason it didn't stick and no we needed
software yeah and monday.com lets us
save hours of time so whitney can focus
more on creative work and things that
make you laugh than like endless work
processes i.e thumb-stopping texts well
yeah and it's also just a very smart
thing to do because i think when you're
running a business the the
tensions come up when there's people
have different work styles and there's
not expectations in place this takes
away all the awkward conversations the
weird
sensitivities i mean the one time i
tried to set a workflow
uh it was
the tears flowed there were i made
sandwiches it was a i i did i tried to
do a peanut butter jelly exercise like
it just if monday.com had been around
two years ago i very much feel like we'd
all look two years younger
what emily's still upset about it
with myspace.com we can customize our
workflows to reflect exactly you can't
be mad in a shirt that says hydrate and
master our team to get work done see
like i can assign certain tasks to
people for whitney i'm like stop making
fun of me for grace i'm like get bangs
and then it gets done we collaborate in
one place and for you we say hydrate
masturbate and then i put on my t-shirt
we collaborate in one place we get
real-time notifications uh when
something is turning red where was that
sweatshirt
i don't think that sweatshirt it was a
quality item i'm starting to think that
maybe that was not a quality made item
and now you're putting it on your face
this was a gift
uh with monday.com from your enemies
do they put small blocks in it is that a
small box blanket it's asbestos just
listen
you're gonna miss me
but you know what
they probably managed to get that done
with monday.com we can track our
progress and get real-time results and
we just keep killing there's like a note
section in ours and it's always like
reminders to do and emily's is just like
quick
all about rosacea quit to start your
free two-week trial go to monday.com
podcast that's monday.com podcast okay
april 13th and april 14th i'm going to
be in la jolla california doing la jolla
comedy store i'm going to be running my
new hour special all new material come
see me complain about things that really
aren't that big of a deal april 22nd i'm
going to be in portland oregon at the
arlene schnitzer concert hall putting on
a concert uh may 20th i'm gonna be in
tyson's corner or a capital one hall
it's just the show's just in the hall
um june 26 in the toronto
area i will be in the danforth music
hall and now back to our guest i was
working on this bit to try to like
defend pedophiles because it was just
like the idea i'm not
i've been working on that same bit and
let me tell you
let's see if we can rocky you know what
let's see if we can crack this today so
well i guess my thing was like if i see
like a like i love little things like
mini like alcohol
oh this
this is a hilarious
like little approach
like i love tiny things
and like whenever i go to like the mini
bar and they have like a tiny like
maker's mark like i have to have it so
funny so i got if
like if you go downstairs that you can
but i give a touchdown
but i like love tiny things like yeah
that makes sense i need this but do you
want to fuck them
well i want to like touch it and like
this is like a little tiny figurine
that's the worst hilarious
that means so much to me and if i just
saw this in the street
i would definitely
try to figure out how to get in my car
yeah okay okay
that is that's you know louis ck's bit
about like
i mean fucking kids must be like great
because they like they risk everything
to do it it must like i'm not i don't
want to do it but like it must be um
amazing like that's a great bit about
about molestation because i feel like i
haven't been molested that i know of
like it could have happened like a lot
of times molestation happens when you're
a baby before you can remember and you
can hold on to that trauma and you don't
know so i don't want to say that i
haven't not to my knowledge i have not
been and it's uncomfortable that i'm not
able to talk about it because if i were
molested i could be like hey i've been
lusted so i can talk about this but i do
believe that we need to talk comedy i
don't want to make jokes at the expense
of people that have been molested ever
ever ever i think that's the other thing
is like i'm feeling so like profoundly
unfunny right now
just like in general
right now or in yeah oh my god i go
through stages like that so much and
yeah i'm with you girl i don't know i
just i do think the will smith like slap
it did make me feel a little bit like
you know i mean to watch like
i was just so hard to fucking talk about
just that the you know one of the best
comedians in the world was just like
treated like that and
you know it just i just it's just weird
to think that we are some of the most
revered in a lot of ways people i think
people like
we're like zoo animals they like respect
us but not enough to like treat us like
equals that's i mean the oscars would be
unwatchable without comedians there's
what do you what are you what would you
what would be watchable about that
watching
actors pretend to have personalities by
reading jokes written for them by
comedians off a teleprompter and then
sometimes flubbing it and that's where
you see a little bit of humanity there's
nothing watchable about the oscars
unless there's singing and dance like
the grammys is watchable that's
entertainment actors aside from the
movie clips you see there's nothing
watchable about that without comics yeah
that's why i went to the show amy and
and wanda and regina were done for the
night i was like okay all the comedy's
done i went to bed and that's why i got
woken up with like oh my god did you see
it like and then and then i had to get
out of bed and i go really get out of
bed they're like get out of bed
and go look at what just happened and
what happened when you saw did you think
it was fake first no i thought it was
real just because of the they
the sound went out and i was like no one
knew about this and just the way
chris rock looked so scared and didn't
know it he didn't have some good
comeback it was just but i do think that
when will smith walked up there he
didn't know what he was gonna do like i
really compare it to when you're like
driving in a car maybe like there's a
crash in front of you and you're like do
i break do i press on the brakes or do i
steer like which one is gonna be the
least painful so he looked at jada and
then he looked at uh chris rock and he
knew he had to either deal with that or
deal with jada and he goes okay the
least painful is this so he starts
walking to the stage the least painful
is ruining your entire career that's why
i'm saying i think on the other end of
that stair is a lot of abuse that we
don't understand and it will never come
out but i don't know about you but i
have been in situations with people
where
the person that might be mad at you
if when they get that look in their face
and you don't make it right right away
that is months of punishment in a way
that is so hurtful whether physical or
emotional of ignoring of just just a
punitive vibe and she calls the shots in
that house i'm not saying i'm not and
listen if she's
if she's a nightmare to be around i also
like it's probably her own something
happened to her that made her that way
like i'm not putting the blame on really
anyone here but i'm just saying
that i saw a man laugh at a joke which
you know he can he can change his mind
about joke it's fine that he laughed but
i saw he made her he made a choice
because of that look that she gave yeah
then he walks to the stage and then he
goes okay so i have two choices here my
choices are
say something to him or
slap him and
i see what that's he's apparently of of
of words you're not gonna go toe-to-toe
with chris rockwell so he goes okay i'm
gonna go with the one that's like i'm
not gonna look as stupid if chris
doesn't have bad choices but those were
his choices if i was in chris rock's
situation and will smith slapped me like
that i would have
yeah well first what do you think you
would have
done all
getting slapped in the face in front of
millions of people is the only way i can
come so i i was like how did you know
number two i think i would be like
hey will that's not how i thought you
were gonna come out as gay but here we
are my god oh my god broadway
slap
what that stage combat you fucking dork
jin i'm saying like do you it was like
such a like neil but like
you know what i mean like cherry hill
theater slap
lee strasburg
i don't know i don't know but i just was
like you play back and it's like boo
it's so uncomfortable oh wow yeah
do you deal a lot with um because people
are always like how do you take on
eglers and i just don't i don't deal
with them
not i do not go at them i
sometimes i feel like they're right ones
now right i mean
people that come to see you i feel like
there's there was during like the trump
eras like things when i was doing clubs
and stuff and people would come because
they saw me on roast and then they go
like
i used to like you because i'd say one
i'd like mention that pence calls his
wife mother or some some facts
and they just they were waiting to hear
it you know they're just waiting for you
to say something against their hat
that's what i believe with their hot
take
if you are a man that is paying money
to hear a woman talk
for
an hour and a half an hour an hour and a
half yeah
and you don't get to say anything or
fuck her at the end i think you are a
radical feminist
even if you come to my show and call me
a horrible cunt that you hate and storm
out i wouldn't eat when i'm like still a
feminist dude i hate to break it to you
but you still paid money to hear me talk
you knew you were never going to fuck me
it's a really good point it's a tricky
one i'm like i still love you man
you're still in most people who didn't
come at all
because they were like women aren't
funny i'm like you at least gave me a
shot oh my god i love that so much like
i just try to like stick with that like
it's really true like there are times
where i'm like i can't i can see the men
kind of just like not wanting to be
there sometimes and just like so mad
that they don't that they have to listen
to this what i see oh maybe that's what
you're projecting on to them you know or
yeah they could just have a hemorrhoid
and they're just shifting in their seat
they're like okay you know like or
something i i don't know i think for me
you're right i for the most part feel
like i've helped people to think they're
being helpful
like oh yeah like i'll be like so the
other day i went to erwin and they're
like and i'm like and i'm like trying to
sort of play a moment for comic timing
or pacing or something and someone's
like the the mangoes and i'm like i got
let's just oh my god that's why i don't
take any pauses i'm so scared it's going
to give the audience a time to like say
something and
that's why i talk
that's so interesting ever let up
because i feel like there's so many
comics i watch now that
take their time
and sit and i'm just i it makes me
nervous because i'm like someone's gonna
shout something there's gonna be some
idiot that's like i love you yeah like
it's always gonna happen
but i feel like to me i i don't know i
guess i'm so i get so sick of myself
like in with these kind of tour
schedules that we're doing right now i
just seem like so sick
that when someone heckles i'm like
please like honestly
i do the same thing there is no way this
is going to go well but i am going to do
the same thing over and over again and
expect a different result after 15 years
of doing this i'm going to throw you the
ball because like wait you know like
maybe you're the one maybe maybe you're
the one that should be up here yes maybe
this is like you're like the i'm ike in
your team i'm like pull someone out of
the crowd that's not what you think of
immediately but he did discover her like
yeah yeah and like or i'm like this
person i'll always be like it seems like
you need to talk
right
like let's go like it doesn't have to be
funny but let's just like get it out
because it's starting to do that i'm
starting to be more comfortable with the
fact of like i have this fail-safe plan
now as a comic where i realized recently
like
whenever i'm bombing or maybe my set has
taken a turn and it's not what i want it
to be i just stop and i go what is
what's the most honest thing you can say
yeah like what just say the truth what
you're feeling it'll be like my pants
are too tight or like
i a lot of you are regretting the money
you spent tonight and i will venmo you
for the babysitter for the extra 15
minutes i'm using to try to dig out of
this whole like just you just stop and
go what's honest because yeah that's
that's the ticket all you have to do is
comedian is just we have a gift of being
honest and it's it it is it's kind of
easy for us luckily like it's comedy is
not easy by any means but in those
moments
being that's where i just go to is the
honesty and a lot of times though i feel
like it's always drunk people and i tend
to go like
i hope this is like a bottom for you
tonight like this no they're going to be
like last night nikki glazer spoke to me
i got to do that exact set of shots
again
that was the magic number now i always
try to make it up that was a sign from
god that i'm going in the right
direction
with the jacobs creek then the champagne
what did i tell you i'm like please
remember this i know that you're on
blackout right now but i want you like
i'm talking to your subconscious mind
remember this and know how embarrassing
this is and get help because this isn't
a good look and you're going to lose
friends i will get really weird i'll be
like and i'll see you back at this
church like one time before i get a
church i was like i'll see you in the
basement of this church tomorrow morning
at 8am
where that person woke up the next day
and was like nikki glaser picked me out
of a crowd i mean that is fine
that's never going to be that's our
connection that was mortified were you
ever did you ever heckle have you ever
been in a situation where you
became that like we're too drunk
you did that you you like have empathy
for hecklers because you've been that
girl i think that part of being a
comedian is knowing on some level like
you have tourettes and you're like
i gotta figure out a career that makes
this seem like everyone's whatever she's
a comedian like i there are times when
someone will be saying
like something like it's when things are
when someone's
number one a bad plan i can't allow a
bad plan to go and i can't oh there's a
couple things where i just cannot sit
and listen
with a bad plan if someone's like okay
we're gonna go to the beach so why don't
i come to west hollywood and pick you up
and then you can drive back to culver
city and then i'll meet you i'm like i'm
gonna stop you right there oh girl
whereas like i just that's like my
version of heckling when i'm like let me
stop you right there like
i i get like really enraged tell me what
to do because this is hitting something
fresh for me that always comes up with
you
when you know that book getting too i do
yeah about feminine masculine energy
i am dealing with is this is what made
you and i become friends it was i agree
it was the straw that broke the camel's
back when i ran into you at the comedy
store you were engaged at the time and i
go what the hell did you do
what did you do to find amanda like
you're in love you you were really happy
at the time and like
and i and you go i i read a book and i
was like and then uh it that book really
sets up i mean i talk about it in my
upcoming hbo special like i talk about
that book that you recommended to me
because but i'm hearing you right now
and i am obsessed with bad plans too
when i hear a bad plan and i know
there's a better route i just know how
to make things very efficient just like
you i have never needed to correct a
plan with you because you have
everything done very like it's gonna you
think the same way i do but when i am
with like someone that i am dating and i
see them have a bad plan and i want to
go hold on a minute here and i need to
save my feminine energy how do you how
do you keep that in it's a tricky well
if you're dating the person you have to
let them do it yeah i know you have to
follow the background isn't that nuts
like you'll be like driving somewhere
and you know that they're going to go 10
minutes out of the way and you're late
but you just have to keep your mouth
shut because
it's not going to be like you need to go
to this exit just left because you have
to relax let them pass the exit let them
pass the exit because even if you say
okay there's the exit that's not what
they're gonna hear they're here like you
have a small dick and i've never come
like you know that's not so funny it's
not going to
translate any way
but i said that that's somebody heard it
doesn't matter what you said you're
right what the person heard is all the
matter ten minutes i would save by going
up that exit i'm gonna lose with all the
bullshit that this little remark is
gonna on the other end of it that's a
good point also just like let him have
it let like you get to have everything
let him have it it's like part of the
like
look at me being like pro straight guy
it's like when people are like why does
water men have to overthink the proposal
because they never get to make any
decision like it is true you know and
they just let him have the exit let him
have the directions let them know we are
so we are such bullies like oh we got
you guys with your fucking directions
and your fucking yeah go your grill
yeah and your fucking video games like
we are so mean yeah i i agree it's it's
been
quite a uh a learning experience just
biting my tongue when it comes to
knowing a better way and knowing that it
is my way is going to be a better way
i've done it many times but what's your
definition of better in that scenario
not being late but then you're gonna be
fighting the whole time and you're gonna
get there faster you're right and it's
gonna be intense and uncomfortable was
it working for me and so i tried this
way and i man i fought it and i did it
it's not about not like i think people
and myself included for a long time
conflated
uh being in any way like docile or
submissive as being weak i think it's
the ultimate form of strength to just go
like
i know the better way but i'm gonna let
you have this one because i surrendered
a human nature and like i now am
ball like man enough to realize that
like in relationships all that matters
is impact it's all that matters
well that was my intention but that was
your impact so it's like in life we're
trying to separate your intention from
your impact like that's you know a big
public conversation that i'm not getting
into in relationships all that matters
is impact
that's interesting because you're right
like it's
i the one thing that i have found what
do you think of this is that men really
wanna make just they wanna know that
they're understood like they wanna they
you even if you're like yeah yeah i know
like you gotta let him say it so many
times and just listen and then say it
back to them like what i'm hearing
is that this like and by the way like
there have been so many times where i'm
like
i i know i know what he's trying to say
and i get it and i disagree with it but
he's allowed to have his feelings and
i'll let him say it and then suddenly
what did you do with time that he said
it i go whoa
okay
i was not actually having empathy i was
sympathizing but i was not seeing it
from his actual point of view and it
took five times to get it and so it's
really helped me to just really shut the
fuck up by the way you ha
by the time i was in like in allen on
for maybe like 10 12 years it's like
your kind of addictions change like you
know what we say like the pair of
alcoholism like i'm addicted to control
i'm addicted to perfection i'm addicted
to other addicts i'm addicted to
mothering murdering micromanaging and i
remember like eight years in i found i
was like you guys i think i'm addicted
to talking
yeah like i can't stop like i
explain minimize apologize like i i
literally will be standing next to
someone i don't know in an elevator and
i'm just like hey so these buttons are
like crazy right i'm gonna like i cannot
be in the silence and then i think i was
so not heard as a child or understood
that i'll say something and then i'll
say it again a different way and then
i'll say it again a different way when
someone like clearly has got it yes you
know oh my god do you ever feel do you
ever get the sense as as a talky woman
myself and a
little chatterbox do you ever sense when
you're being a lot and you catch someone
like looking at another person about you
and you go oh god i'm that person like
that is so embarrassing to me and so
many times in my childhood i'd get like
just keep it down like just start just
shh like give me an example like in
conversation or just like some like i'll
just be talking and i'll be like really
excited about something and i'm like yes
and i'll be on like my little like
soapbox and i'll just catch them look at
someone like
okay like where you just can you let
that slide well yeah because i think i
got that a lot as a kid where my parents
didn't know what to do with me what was
that oh really i would go okay got it
and i'm going to stop talking and shut
up and like take this to um a lot of
food later on alone in my room like it i
will go like they're right because i
think my earliest memory is like
throwing tantrums or freaking out about
something or like having a fabric on me
that was just like i hate socks and like
not understanding like how to describe
like what was making me so insane
because my barbie doll had weird hair
and it wasn't perfect and i would just
be like
like when things weren't perfect i would
freak out and i would just see my
parents go like nikki
you need to this is this is embarrassing
and i'd see them like look at each other
like
oh my and those glances that might be a
special problem that we can't even we
can't even put into words what's wrong
with this girl and she
she's weird they say one of the most
dramatic things you can do to um babies
with like their bodies is when you're
changing their diaper to like like
couples that are like ew it stinks like
you're like making a joke or you're just
you know it's poop but just the idea of
like you're like new parents that you're
like oh gross change the diet you know
like tristan even if you're joking
babies subconsciously are like oh
something down there is like is making
them laugh or making them go or making
them
yeah i mean babies can see a picture of
a spider and recoil because that's how
deep it is in our like genetic which
makes me have we talked about your
ancestral trauma because i feel like
there's like a lot there i am now
believing in that stuff of like reading
irrational fears or just yeah they seem
irrational but they're not they are
ancestors basically imprinted on their
dna so it's like you cannot refute that
like you know the um uh that mice when
they get not that i love that um there
is testing on animals but it is what it
is i didn't do it uh just get out calm
down uh so basically uh that uh mice
when they were electrocuted every time
they smelled a cherry blossom their
offspring if they smelled a cherry
blossom would run to the other end of
the cage like it's that quick how it
duplicates so like fear of heights like
it's you know some people are just like
irrationally afraid of heights i think
everyone should be fucking afraid of
heights i think it's weird if you're not
but it's like it could mean that one of
your ancestors you know fell off a cliff
it makes absolute sense it's like in
your research what are your irrational
fears mine well actually mine is more an
irrational like sadness that comes up to
me it doesn't seem irrational but it is
um after i did my family constellation i
kind of figured out what it was and
family consolation is like pseudoscience
so what were you saying about the
constellation and the uh the the family
so i cannot go to midtown in new york i
don't go to i love new york city i just
cannot go there because of the horse
carriages it's too stressful for it just
i can't
handle it um and uh it makes me like
like violently enraged and i'm like the
crazy person like yelling at tourists
and so you've done that before you've
yeah yeah oh yeah because i i i've
negotiated with them to try to get
horses out i tried to get one of the
horses out that was 32 years old it was
gonna die at any minute it's like
it's very tricky because the guys that
own their horses it's like cabs like
they own the horse it's not you know
what i mean so it's also there they see
it as property it's like very hard to
get between and they in some sick way
believe they love this animal you know
but um but so i would like when i would
have to do letterman or tonight's show
or whatever was like in midtown like if
i heard even the clothing i would
i mean i had to put i was gonna do the
view i'd like push it to the next day
because i was sobbing so uncontrollably
like i called like yes there's kids at
the border there's people dying
everywhere it's like i
i ca it makes me so upset i remember one
time i was with this guy i was dating
and i was like uncontrollably sobbing
because he promised me that the way the
routes went we were like on the other
side of the park and i would just wear
noise-canceling headphones like just as
i'm going through whitney so what is
that so one time he like had to pull me
into like a museum uh because i was
crying so much i don't remember whatever
is the one up on the upper east side or
whatever completely you have to go and
we go in and like every painting is like
a horse-drawn carrot oh my god oh no and
i'm like having a total meltdown in this
fucking museum and i like how bridgerton
is like the movie saw for you i can't
watch i can't watch any movies with i
would love to i hear yellowstone's
amazing i just can't watch it yeah so
anything that has horses like they're
doing a better job like i'm working with
a couple actors and directors right now
on like how to have horses and movies in
a way that's actually like humane and
consensual but like i mean the way that
i remember that dustin hoffman show
where a couple horses died the race were
i mean racehor
racing is the worst thing um you can
possibly do but they used to the way
they used to you know they would trip
wire horses in movies like any western
rehearsal when they fall oh my god you
know i just like i can't get over it i
can see other stuff and get over it you
know it's like emily talks about like
her intrusive thoughts are different
yours are more like kids like mine or if
i see animal abuse like i just
i i like
yeah so yeah i do this family
constellation theory thing and i'm like
this is kind of food i'm like always
whatever i'm always a comedian about it
i'm like this is some like whatever why
am i paying you by check like this is
not the thing
like you're clearing my energy cool okay
oh my god and uh and so she like has you
like stand on all these things and you
know she finally was like um
you know your
uh great great grandfather like do you
know anything about him like and i was
like no what like
coal miner west virginia you know
they're like well he did something
unforgivable i'm like yeah guys that
long ago were all yeah no shit that's
probably how it was made yeah by the way
the rapings stealing from the native
americans like yeah what did he do
anything good that would be the standout
with hot takes and innovative solutions
so i
he she says she also says what your
great-great-grandfather did is
unforgivable and
your grand great-great-grandmother the
way that she punished him was that she
withheld her love
and it's a small thing but that's
exactly what i do that's exactly what i
do i don't scream i don't yell i
withhold my luck yeah i ice you the fuck
out and it's like it's really hard for
me to stop wow i mean to your point
about like not being conscious like this
is like normally i can go like take a
contrary action just go home
in relationships when you get hurt or
you something comes up that's what
you'll do in like romantic relationships
friendships like what's
like friendships that scare me a little
bit i will
kind of be in denial like i'll go if
like if you were just right now freak
out and be like fuck you and just do
something super weird or mean or just
snap on me or be like i don't like how
this is going you're not being funny
enough like whatever um and left i would
pretend it didn't happen
i mean as of that was like the coping
mechanism as of recently right uh i hope
i'd be a little more conscious but i
would kind of pretend it didn't happen
right but the when where when would you
ice people when was that i'm in like a
romantic relationship with somebody yeah
oh my god
but i can't get out of it that is what
a partner i used to have used to have
the same thing and i i'm i used to have
a joke about it my act and saying like
there were times where i was like can
you just hit me instead of this because
it would be quicker at least you would
be touching me and i like because it
would be
so painful because i would do something
that i didn't know what would happen and
this person would shut down and just
like act like no no no everything's fine
it's fine would you like to touch me i
like to do a joke i think it's my first
special about how when we um ice guys
out it's not a punishment it's a reward
i think i'm like he's like treatment
thank god no but but for me so
he but he used to say i cannot
help it i don't know what to do and i'm
not it's nice i
i'm able to kind of say like this is my
inner child shutting down and just wants
to go hide and i'm going to need a
couple days otherwise if you put if you
push me i'm going to say something i
regret right it's going to change the
way you view yourself forever you do not
want me
being anything but silent right now yes
because i want to hurt you so bad that's
the kindest thing i hurt and it's just
like a it just let me let me have the
dignity of my own experience let me not
fuck this up i i
day two and three is all just
embarrassment from day one of doing it
and then you have to maintain it now i'm
embarrassed that that was my coping
mechanism like what kind of child is
like i'm not gonna talk to you like and
then you're just then you're just
embarrassed that you did that yeah and
then because then you have to be the
asshole that goes back comes back with
your tablet and you're like hey i'm
ready to talk to you again like you can
come into my tree house now yeah like
you're just such a child you know so
it's like day two and three it's i'm
embarrassed and now i'm just like it's
just my pride i guess and then it's like
you want coffee like then it just has to
be like fuck how do you get how do you
handle that now do you still do it or do
you is there a way that you can not do
that i am able to go hey
sorry
like he's i'm with someone right now who
is like so non-judgmental and is so
ready to drop the charges at any moment
and there's times that he will get upset
at me about things that i truly do not
understand and i'm grateful for it like
tell me you tell me
emily knew right away
what went sideways on this situation so
i am 39 years old i froze my eggs the
guy that i'm with is 31 we're like let's
freeze embryos right like we should
freeze embryos that would just be a
thing to do to take the pressure off
don't know if i'll ever use them get a
surrogate whatever and so um let's just
knock it out right because i like i mean
it's like before tour i have like three
months i don't want to be doing like
hormone shots on tour like me you know
some people like go on vacation
monsters i know right by the way what is
more stressful than a vacation i love i
do know about myself i love planning a
vacation i don't like being on a
vacation so you like working i mean we
just don't live in hotels like there's
no like i can't so um uh so okay so
there's the fertility doctor that is
available via zoom whenever he is not
working okay he's a full-time vet he was
like studying for some specialized
boards or something which is whatever
it's very it's a big deal but he was
done at eight o'clock and he like comes
in and i had scheduled the fertility
doctor for 8 30
and i was gonna do it with or without
him okay right
the fertility doctor comes on i'm
basically just saying like how much time
do i have the eggs like just whatever
and he's like there and i was like oh
hey
i'm do the fertility doctor can talk now
do you want to just hop on he was like
yeah sure and then he comes on and we
have this like great conversation about
like okay you have plenty of time until
you're this
and we're like cool okay so we'll sprees
um uh free sperm and whatever sorry i've
been talking all day and i'm getting
locked up but uh it's like well free
spirit like we made a plan yeah like
when it worked for him whenever for me
computer closes what the fuck was that
wait you were him him
okay so he felt like he was pulled into
this and if he was he was put in a
position that the doctor would have
thought he was like a bad unsupportive
boyfriend had he said he didn't want to
be a part of the conversation is that
his argument interesting that he put him
on the spot of like i'm not gonna say no
to going on this conversation aren't
these the same guys that are like when
he pulled his dick out why didn't she
just leave the room
[Laughter]
you could have been like
you could have walked by he wasn't in
you could walk behind the computer and
been like
like i didn't like we talked about
having this conversation at some point i
just was like i'm scheduling this if you
want to join if you don't i just assume
that everyone's gonna tell the truth of
if they would like to i would just be
like
like ah you know what he's scared
is he scared he's scared oh like is he
scared that that might disappoint you or
that he might look
maybe he's scared that if he didn't want
to do it that doctor might go like hey
by the way i just saw the way that your
guy like reacted maybe you shouldn't be
doing this with him and like getting
your ear but like it's imagine a doctor
doing that i don't know like what kind
of insurance do you like maybe this is
the way it's like
i don't know what was his what did he
say though he was just like that was you
should have told me that was happening i
was like well i believe the most
respectful thing i could have done at
that moment was schedule it if you can
do it great if not fine right it's i
would have done it without you i don't
like having kids or this quality i will
do it with or without you right if you
want to join great like i just didn't
think i feel like he was like signing on
like i have to have kids now you know
what it is freaking out i am so
far away from doing anything out of
obligation anymore that it blows my mind
that someone's like well that's someone
you love just did something out of
obligation but it's just like he said i
was doing that at 31 like i was just
like oh yeah i'll just just say somebody
will talk to me i'll talk to them that's
like the only time i'm like there is a
certain wisdom that maybe only comes
with age or if you haven't like done
work around codependence which is the
motherfucker i'm like what why would you
sit on a call if you didn't want to like
it blows whitney i totally agree with
you and he's like well it was it would
have been rude i had to be polite and
i'm like i am
to me at this point in my life i see it
is so much more rude to sit and do
something you don't want to do and then
i when i when i see my friends doing
things they don't want to do or putting
up with people in their lives my parents
might like anyone i just go
it i think it makes me feel unsafe
because i'm like well do you just do you
hang out with me what else are you doing
that you don't want to do
because you really pull that i want to
be with someone who respects themselves
enough to go to know their boundaries
and know that they're not wrong to say i
don't want this right now like no is a
full sentence and i i really get upset
when my friends don't utilize it it's in
the same way but then it's also about
one it's also me trying to control which
is why you want to do it i know but
that's that's the main thing because
it's like you know like when you see
people in bad relationships and you're
like well good and you're like they
don't think they're in a bad
relationship yes or they wouldn't be in
it you're just gonna come off cunty and
judgey yes they're just like she's
jealous like you cannot when has anyone
ever been like hey you're in a toxic
relationship you should get out of it
you're like and they go oh my god oh my
god
thank you i did not know thank you so
much i'm gonna cancel that appointment
at the tattoo parlor
right now
i am going to
like it's never happened you have to let
it run its course toxic relationships um
people that are in addictions like
there's just no because i get a lot of
people asking me because of i've been so
open about eating disorder stuff like
hey my sister is anorexic and it's very
clear and what should i do and i just
say
i don't
there is nothing you can say honestly
there's nothing that you there was
literally and i try to think back to
what my mindset is and what i always say
to people now i've watched that elena
morissette documentary did you watch
that i mean
yeah i mean yes it was so freaking good
she was talking about
being i think though she didn't like it
or something so i i know i'm a little
right but there was a part that i that i
think really helped me and helped others
is that
she was saying that she was bulimic and
didn't know what to do and that her
friend walked in on her doing it and all
her friend did was just hug her and say
i love you and it wasn't like i'm
worried about you what are you doing to
yourself i don't understand this and
bulimia by
by a large margin is the most like
shameful of the eating disorders and
insidious in terms of like it's the
disease that tells you you don't have a
disease and it's like that was the last
time and that was that didn't happen you
can just like block it out and it's it's
just so gross you have to clean the
toilet all the time you smell but you
can disassociate while it's happening
totally you know what i mean so for that
really struck me because i go that's
what i want is like that's what i could
have needed when i was struggling when i
and i struggle with stuff now like
sometimes i'm
become a really big bitch or i'm like
you know not getting enough sleep and so
i'm just not treating people well or i'm
too controlling and and i always tell my
friends like when i get in that
when i'm in that state of mind you're
not going to get through me you just
have to say like hey i love you and when
you're ready to talk about whatever you
want to talk about i'm here for you and
that's really all you can do for them
it's also eating disorders are like the
main thing is control so it's like the
more you try to control someone with it
the more they're going to recoil into
their disease it's just like the i mean
it's just one time i gave a girl a note
at a um
at a gym i was it was before i was
performing at the dc improv and there
was this girl on a
stair climber and i was there working
out too yeah or didn't need to be of
course
so who am i to do but i was at a point
where i felt recovered wasn't at all but
like no one would have seen it on me but
i saw her and i was just like like she
just looked like she was about to break
and i was her so many times and i
remember just being like
what would you want and so i wrote i
went in the locker room and i like
wrote this like shaky note of like hey
i've been there like i
no judgment
like if you ever want to talk to someone
about what you're going through with no
judgment like reach out to me and i like
wrote my name and stuff and she never
said your secret and i just what ps
what's your secret yeah
it's like how many calories
yes
did you order something you're curious
yeah yeah diet sunk is just curious just
curious
i won't tell anyone
how much how much oh my god uh and i i
remembered i just walked her door and
was like here that like just gave it to
her and there's
you know i look back on that and i go i
probably shouldn't have done that but um
you just wanna there's just no way to
get through sometimes i don't know what
the
a seed whatever it is i look back at any
time someone was like worried about me
when i really bad eating disorders like
what they didn't understand is i was
like nailed it like i'm on there you
know what i mean or if someone was like
you looked are you okay i'd be like okay
the rice cakes are working like if they
didn't understand that it was
the way that it goes through your brain
when people stop worrying about you
that's when you're like once you're like
oh yeah it's like you look so healthy
and you're like okay you shouldn't have
had that pear or whatever you know what
i mean so it's like they don't
understand that when you're saying
something it's going through this
dysmorphia machine and turning into
something completely different hey kiddo
hey man uh we're now taking a break from
this dazzling guest um that hopefully
isn't such a specific guest you're such
like you're like
you know who it is
you know who it is you can't put your
finger on it are you eating while we're
recording no okay so catalina crunch is
so delicious that grace has broke the
main rule of podcasting which is don't
eat while you're doing it so sorry it's
so good
i started eating it before we started
rolling and now i can't stop eating it
so we have um a neuroscience professor
here tell we keto is the way to go for
your brain right it is very useful yes
and then generally i think it looks good
i mean i've never tried but it sounds
great it is
no sugar all good it is so delicious
it is i've never looked better
they have eight crave worthy flavors to
choose from like nostalgia inducing
um cinnamon toast which is what you have
right there ah zero gram sugar 11 gram
protein and nine gram fiber yeah that's
huge that's wild you can have cinnamon
toast decadent chocolate creamy
chocolate peanut butter holy mackerel if
you're not sure what flavor to try first
that's what the variety packs are good
story it says catalina snacks was funded
by a diabetic who believes you can enjoy
great tasting cereals and snacks
earnestly made with protein fiber and
good fats while minimizing sugars
combining nutritional science with
culinary arts we have created delicious
healthier products that help you achieve
a better life it's gluten-free
grain-free non-gmo only real clean
ingredients but nothing artificial i'm
sorry about the diabetes that sounds
awful um but thank you i'm really glad
we got the cereal out of it uh see why
catalina crunch cereal is the fastest
growing cereal brand in
america and soon to be all other
places just go to catalinacrunch.com
whitney for 15 off your first order plus
free shipping that's
catalinacrunch.comwhitney
not sure which flavor to start with try
a variety pack and check out the
delicious cookies and snack mixes while
you're at it again that's
catalinacrunch.com whitney for 15 off
your first order plus free shipping look
frank's trying to get it out of my mouth
um we were just talking about sleep and
how important sleep is and again we have
a neuroscience professor here right now
because we just want to make sure
everything we're saying is true so we
now just have him here at all times to
make sure
he can corroborate everything we're
saying how important is sleep
very important very important but
sometimes it's hard to get to sleep
because sometimes i'm a silly goose and
i'll just like have a latte at 6 p.m
that's true you want better sleep and
you know that i will look at my phone up
until the buzzer i mean i'm like i will
look at my phone in bed i'm not doing
this thing we put you have to put your
phone outside your room you can't look
at your phone three hours before bed i
don't
whose life can can have make those
choices can i tell you something yeah um
ever since i started using beam
i have decided that like when i take my
first sift that's when my do not disturb
goes on at night
so if you see the little dot a little
earlier if you see that
if you see that crazy notification of 6
15 uh okay
that's part of your ritual that's part
of my that's part of my routine now i
love it it's like um it tastes like hot
chocolate but like not sickeningly sweet
it's delicious it just like calms me
down and
gets me ready for night night time so
sleep i have struggled with sleep my
entire life and um this is like a
miracle it has l-theanine right
melatonin
go on and magnesium what is the other
thing that yeah those are all the most
sophomoric things true of course that's
a big one impressive
so we are introducing for you guys beam
dream beam is the world's most
innovative functional wellness brand
with unique products for everything from
sleep to recovery for so many dots
it's
we're trying to get through this but
dogs do keep coming in i know these are
gonna we need to feed them beans i
haven't even seen them i know it was
right now exactly the door was closed it
was fully closed um beam is so good if
bill cosby were still at it he just used
beam
it says no thc just tlc this is my this
is my policy no tft just tlc
it contains natural sleep promoting
premium ingredients triple
laptops feeling refreshed
mona come here she's so excited okay 98
of people surveyed fall asleep faster
when taking beam dream and 99 of people
experience better sleep quality so what
are you waiting for
if you don't love it which would be
psychotic um
get your money back guarantee don't lose
sleep over it
gfi and use code gfi at checkout that's
b e a m organics.com slash gfi and um
why it's true gfy thank you
not that good gfy and use code gfy for
20 off sometimes when i'm in
the body obsession and
like i'm not getting enough sleep i'm
depressed it goes into my body and it
and i think and i am in recovery from
eating eating disorder but
things flare up and someone wrote to me
today and was like hey i just want to
let you know like what you said about
camila cabello or what like and i didn't
say anything mean but i i said something
like i said something that made this
girl go no wonder girls feel that and i
was like oh my god thank you
for holding a mirror up because i'm in
the fucking disease right now and i'm
talking like a crazy person in the way
that i'm like i don't even realize it
yeah i think it can just get
it's just my go-to thing and obviously
like i'm i'm
i'm always like reluctant to ever talk
about this stuff because it's just like
that's like her thing all she talks
about is her eating disorder but i just
feel like i don't know it can be like
cabello no me like i feel like i i it's
just so much of like what like even last
night i saw my mark mayor and i'm like
i'd love to do your podcast again he's
like what are we going to talk about
eating disorders and i go probably
actually because i've got new ones since
the last time i went on that i've ready
to talk about but like
i just i'd never want to be the the
eating disorder girl but i do find that
doing enough podcasts like i start to
notice patterns that i'm like oh you're
talking a lot about size and stuff and
i'm like examine that and but what do
you think that you are saying it to like
get ahead of someone thinking it like
i'm going to talk about the fact that i
didn't before you can even think about
it or maybe you know like do you feel
like it's like a subconscious way of
trying to control it like i find myself
doing it
more with like looking older i'm like
yeah i know because i look like stevie
chamier like i'm like why am i bringing
this up like why am i it hurts me so
much when people make these comments and
i'm doing it about myself i guess just
to be like i know you're what you're uh
let me
it's like a it's like a tick
as we're recording this i am trying i'm
thinking
what comics are going to say about
you and i and how like
we only talked about the same like i'm
i'm already formulating the youtube
comments in my head and trying to get
trying to say exactly what they are
typing as they're typing it so that they
can go well no i can't write that like
i'm always trying to beat them to it
yeah and what it does is it actually
just creates the the the thing that
isn't even there let me out for your na
like what is your dream for the next
like five ten years oh that's because i
look and it's like you have this reality
show coming out and you have the um
you're just on the fuckboy island too
and like you're just like what are you
cuz i realized this the other day i was
like
i am like i'm not getting what i want
and i want and i'm like i haven't
thought about i don't know why maybe
it's just since the pandemic i used to
have like vision boards and lists and
now
yeah oh yeah i have never had that stuff
i am like i now feel like i am just like
ad hoc being like okay i guess i'll do
movies like you know what i guess i'll
make this show maybe that's a healthier
way to do it yeah but i also was like if
someone asked me what i did want i don't
even know if i could answer it i know i
i really i've never had like goals i'm
so like one day at a time program like
don't think ahead don't future fuck like
let you know like i try to do that too
i think i just want to like be really
comfortable with myself like that is my
goal is just to be
just to be okay with whatever people
think about me and try and while at the
same time try not to fall out of favor
because i'm so worried about i really
like the level of
fame that i have quote unquote fame yeah
because it's at a level where people are
like she doesn't get the like she
deserves more like we'd like to see more
of her yeah because the second i get it
they'll go we're good yeah yeah
i think that when we signed up to be
famous it was a different kind of fame
it was like what you said when you were
15 is water under the bridge like those
halloween costumes when you were sick
like fame when we signed up to be famous
was like you were more of an enigma like
you didn't like
you know if someone had told me that
like i was like i want to be a comedian
if they're like okay just you know in 15
years you're gonna every week have to
talk about your mental illness for four
hours
and you talk into a phone and be like
come to my show hey guys hey guys
people right now are saying no you don't
win you don't have to talk about it
you're choosing to but it's like no
we kind of this is this is it this is
the talent you're obsessed with me um
i'm not doing this i'm not playing the
game of like i'm not doing this i'm not
doing this i love that yeah like okay
i didn't read that comment you just left
so the only thing the only thing uh
the fact that you even think i read your
mean comment is the harshest thing i can
do to you that's so funny the fact that
you just said that and i didn't even see
it
if you're leaving mean comments about me
and i'm not reading them like i'm so
sorry for you
i didn't even see it i feel like every
10 years five to ten years i just i want
to um
i want to be getting really good sleep i
want to like the way i look and be like
okay with it i want to keep growing and
working on acceptance i want to like
i want
to just i don't know i would like to
keep doing reality television because
it's fucking you love it i love it it's
so easy you don't have to learn lines
you just be yourself you just be
vulnerable you just be honest like this
show that i'm doing with e which is like
i'm replacing the kardashian show like
they're kind of banking on this show
being like the new thing and it's a lot
of pressure but it's also like it was it
came out of me being like i just don't
want to i want to do stuff with my
family and my friends we're funny and i
just don't want to memorize lines and i
don't want to have to write things and i
just i'm just lazy i want to just show
up start talking and be it is kind of
weird like as i'm like when people want
to do more acting it there is someone
like went to actually like i wanted that
but there was something so weird about
like i feel like i signed up to do more
acting when i hated being in my own skin
and i hated my like now that i like like
myself and i'm like feel like i'm like
funny and interesting now i'm like now
i'm gonna go play this hooker like why
like you know what i'm saying like it's
just like a little bit weird like why am
i gonna go play a dumb person in atlanta
for two months yes you know what i mean
like we have a talent of being able to
be ourselves we are not reality stars in
the sense that
we are just belligerent on camera i mean
sometimes but like we
i think our talent is like
being expected
ourselves being honest like really
honest and i'm so grateful that there's
like a way that i can do that and people
are entertained by it like it's just an
f-boy island is so fun and easy i just
watch a reality show happen
it happens before you there's no way to
plan for it so it just you you don't
have to like there's no work involved
you just show up and i go so who are you
eliminating tonight and then i go oh my
god like and i just respond to it i just
get to the the only hard part is like
hair and makeup but that is that's
lovely because i could hang out with my
friends and get my face painted but tell
me why i felt it feels like you said you
were like having a hard time there i was
having a hard time there because i
because it was coveted and there was a
lot there wasn't many interactions on
set when i did fy1 we were in cayman
islands and it was 2021 but there was no
coat fit on the island we quarantined
for two weeks and then it was like
summer camp and we could see faces and
this was very much like quarantine stick
with your truck like little tribe and
like onset was only time that i got felt
like able to be free and i was kind of
at a hotel away from everyone else
because they were scared that i was
gonna maybe like fuck someone outside i
don't know
they'd kept me like away from people so
i was just like in this basement at this
luxury resort and it was like a dark
room that didn't have enough lighting i
was just depressed
but
the show itself is the sweetest gig yeah
yeah it's i do ever get like sometimes
when i see people like like reality show
contestants if i'm around them too but
like the ones that are like signing up
to kind of be humiliated like signing up
for the shot in florida where it's like
my biggest fear is being embarrassed and
these people are like i there's no there
is no way i'm not going to come out of
this not being embarrassed in some way
yes yes and like
what kind of person that is and like i i
don't know after talking to things mark
burnett uh someone told me that mark
burnett was saying that the number of
people that are on reality shows his
contestants that commit suicide is like
wild because after they are like didn't
really sign up to be famous they kind of
fell into it then all of a sudden they
had like they got humiliated or who
knows they have 15 minutes to know what
you think you're going to go in and know
that you can control it and
be the version of yourself that you want
to be and you can only hold on to that
for so long because
it's too ex it's like doing a plank you
can hold it for like yes
and then you just relax your posture
gets bad your anger shows on your face
and you become the sometimes
quite often the worst version of
yourself because you're in a habitat
that is built to bring that out and it
will be brought out it's a prison
experiment they'll get you one hundred
percent you know and i'm lord of the
flies that's why i i really like my job
because i feel like i bring a lot of
empathy to it and i
i love the cast members and i respect
them so much because i'm like you guys
say what everyone's going to judge you
for being on a reality show and this is
fake and lightning
star you're braver than anyone judging
you at home because none of those people
watching you at home and being like i
would never do that they would never
ever
put themselves in a situation where we
see the real them and we're seeing the
real you and you guys i give them a
little speech like any time that i feel
like their morale is slipping of like
you guys are really brave taking this on
this is not easy and i respect the hell
out of them it's like nfl players
getting concussions you're doing this
for other people's entertainment and
it's also like life is such a like a
shit show at this point it's just kind
of like
i don't know it's like the realest thing
you can do now is be a contestant on a
reality shit it really is it's like
watching one just everything is so
truman show at this point and like meta
on meta on meta and it's really like
yeah if you haven't because we're all on
our own i'm anyone that's judging
someone on a reality show who's like
sitting around talking to their phone
you're on we all have our own reality
show in our phone you know this is kind
of like um you know it's just
fascinating to me and i remember uh a
friend of mine pitched an idea to mark
burnett and this was the idea i think
i'm getting it right it was 12
contestants in a room no cell phones
nothing
12 people in a room uh just white walls
beds like for everybody nothing else
and then the ceilings are
17 feet high
and
you know it's why it doesn't matter how
wide it is and then hanging from the
ceiling is a million dollars just cash
and that's it
and they just film it
i'm in i mean that is like 17 feet above
that squid game episode four yeah and
then uh the reality producer was like
people will die yes within two days
someone will die it's um you just cannot
put humans in that situation it's
being so when i hosted f-boy i was
removed from it like i see it happen and
that's as the host i'm protected like i
am not susceptible to any like i get
emotional and i get wrapped up in the
storylines and i
feel all i know that the emotions are
real but then when i did this show for e
i was suddenly like the subject and i
had to really trust like okay are they
going to portray me in a way that i
don't want like am i gonna and then i
realized okay they assured me like we
want people to like you you're likable
that's why we know what's going on yeah
it's our goal but then there's also you
know i've seen the kardashians very
unlikable and they are you know but
that's your
you know what i'm saying i think we
like i mean in terms of kardashians i'm
always like when i'm like well
everybody hates them we obviously don't
hate him that much we obviously see
parts of us and the more sometimes
despicable someone else's behavior is or
whatever it's all you know
look at what your bias is oh i don't
like women being ambitious oh i don't
like women thinking they're pr i don't
like women wanting stuff like i think
the kardashians really hold up a mirror
to like our internalized misogyny our
weird body shit are weird like who do
they think they are like yeah you know
like just plastic shirt like it's just
they are like these um
uh what is it like uh like a catharsis
for us where we're just able to kind of
like
i don't know like beat up on them in a
way and they're just like having the
last laugh i think they know on some
level like being hated is just
it's just you become a billionaire
you're right yeah
it's like you know i and it's also i
think that a lot of people you know i
think we go as people that are like
about being humble and have shame and
don't want to be too big and you know at
the same time like i want to you know uh
be a performer but i don't want to like
take too much attention i'm sorry for
you know whatever like they're just like
yeah we don't really have any skills
except we like ourselves and we're like
what
we have a bunch of skills and we hate
ourselves yes that's not fair oh my gosh
it's like the one thing they have we
can't figure out yeah that is a really
write a script i can do this i can do a
podcast i can start a business and like
yeah we just kind of like ourselves and
we're looking for what happens how how
did you get that just like and i am so
like i'm always like okay what can i
learn from this person instead of like
hating on this person or criticizing
this person
that's what the losers do they sit
around and they just like hate on the
person i'm like what can i learn from
this person you know what i mean and i'm
just always trying to like figure it out
and
i'm getting more and more on the train
of this is something people might think
i already have but i really don't of
delusional confidence
okay yeah delusional confidence i have
delusional insecurity so why not also
have some delusional confidence i love
that why not like by the way i've done
the other one because the delusional
insecurity i feel sometimes like people
go
nikki no that's not the way it is and i
go you don't get it
like i'll say something about myself
that i believe that is delusional
insecurity let's say and then someone
will go you don't see the way i see you
and i'm like well you are stupid then
because your opinion doesn't matter to
me yeah i like that's what i feel like
i'm allowed i'm allowed to not not
listen to the haters why should i listen
to the lovers either
yeah because it works better yeah it's
better business yeah so i think that
listening i think the most successful
people they are able to take criticism
from smart people
and then ignore
just hate from dumb people you know
right take the good and leave them back
because sometimes like all over my
comments and people say stuff i'm like
yeah i interrupt too much i should stop
that is good stuff i say like too much
yes you're an unfuckable cunt
my the thing i hate so much in my dms is
like i love you but but i always open
those because i go it's starting with
love this person yeah uh honestly is
saying this from a place of like hey i'm
not gonna give up on you but as a front
because i do feel like people on my that
list in my podcast know me very
intimately yeah more so than some of my
friends so i do always implore my
listeners to like if i get something
wrong let me know and what is the what
is the fee because i get a couple things
well first of all i get i if i open my
dms it's all like your computer screen's
dirty it has fingerprints on it yeah oh
my god
because you type on it
that's that's great feedback i would
love that it's a lot of that it's a lot
of you know but let me what is like
because i don't really go through the
dms and i to me i the same way that i
don't either but when i do see stuff but
my biggest my biggest issue with the
podcast is there's no feedback like i
want feedback i signed up to be a
comedian that if you laugh at the joke
i'll keep it and if you don't laugh i'm
going to cut it like i want feedback
like i'm able to really not take it
personally my thing is like comedy is
democracy and like in terms of the
podcast i feel like i'm just like
blathering into a black hole normal
sorry normal people that watch it and
enjoy it don't comment that's right
is that stupid when has lots of you
commented on ever in my life unless it's
positive i've never i've never given a
criticism on a comment i don't think the
way that we used to bully each other is
we would like egg houses and like smash
mailboxes like that you know this is
just what i'm sure that young people
like you would if you got mad at someone
you would just throw eggs at their home
like we just send like a little dm
saying you suck you should like kill
yourself yeah like we think they're
crazy
we're leaving us as comments and we're
like well we used to just smash
someone's mailbox driving 70 miles an
hour
and they're like uh we're just like i
feel like the girls that were popular
got toilet paper are like tp and stuff
like they would throw a toilet
for someone to tv
like used to throw toilet paper
like for no reason you know so it's like
i do i'm always trying to be open to
going like okay maybe that's something i
need to believe to like get through the
day yeah maybe that's something i'm
telling myself well i think that on this
reality show i think what the side of
myself that i'm going to see that i used
to see in home videos of myself is that
i'm a brat sometimes i can be really
mean to the people i love the most and a
little bit of a you know teenage brat
and like i think it it's helpful because
just like i'll be like wow you should
sit up straighter like i'll see a side
of myself that i'm like okay i didn't
even realize i talked like that or i'm
not listening to people whatever it is
so you can kind of get away with it yeah
i can't get away with it being what it's
like it's like she's like in a bad mood
oh no i don't get away with it people
are like you're a con you're like a
nasty bit like people really make me
feel bad about being a bitch because i i
i really think that i'm a nice person
most of the time yeah i want the best
for people but there is a side of myself
that can be really mean to
my mom to my best friend andrew my
co-host sometimes like i will take out
my own insecure like i'll be feeling bad
about myself that day and i want him to
be in the same mood and if he's in a
good mood i'll try to take him out of it
and these are things i'm disgusted by
about myself but i i have to get honest
about them in my podcast and my
listeners bringing them to light of like
i can't listen to you anymore because
you're so mean to andrew
made me go
what are they talking about and then i
listen back and i go i wasn't that but
you know but there were yeah where i go
ouch
were you trying to hurt them were you
trying to hurt never intentionally it's
all subconsciously but i don't know what
it is it's me being like i'm scared that
if you feel too big for your bridges
you're going to leave me and not be my
friend
you're dependent on me as my co-host so
i don't want you to get excited about
the thing that doesn't involve me
because then if you get that thing
you're gonna be like i don't need to
hang out with her anymore i was only
doing this i'm insecure that he's not my
friend and the thing i'm most scared of
is you abandoning me so i'm gonna treat
you the way that ensures that you're
gonna leave yes these like deepest most
tragic irony yes it's like it's it was a
rude awakening but it was what thank god
that i got to see it because i'm i was
i'm so myself on my podcast that i see
bad sides of myself and i've been called
out for it but this show it's like i'm
gonna see it and
i think but this show i will say like as
dumb and cliche as it sounds like i
cannot believe how just doing eight
episodes of the show like really changed
my relationship with my family with the
guy i was dating like i it forces you to
be in circumstances and have
conversations that you wouldn't have
and i mean standards came up like
like just like
things that i've never articulated to my
parents about frustrations about feeling
honestly feeling like
why do you like like do you i know you
say you love me like why like i remember
from my mom
uh saying like we love having nikki home
that was a big thing of like nikki's
back home that's you know moving back
home to st louis she's like we love
having her home and i just go why
just i want you to elaborate like why do
you like me
yeah and she was like we just do and i
go like
it's because i'm like fun and like i
make you feel good or like i'm funny and
she's just like because you're my
daughter and i like it yeah what choice
do i have and i just wanted to hear like
things about me she liked but she
couldn't articulate it and then
everyone's like easy nicki like don't
make her say
because you're you came out of her and
she loves you you just made me think of
something wild which i've never thought
of which is like you know the idea of
like
having a kid that's like you of course
you love your daughter of course you
love your kid yeah but
if you hate parts of yourself and that
is showing up in your child
you're just seeing things that you hate
in yourself
in a thing and the anger of like
or your ex-husband yeah exactly exactly
how could a child not feel
detestable if you if they look like your
ex-husband who you hate all the time but
i always worry about that which by the
way always worry about that because like
i mean say half of people are divorced
or just like you know i mean i was
pitted against it was like your mom lies
about this and the reason you can't have
this is because your dad didn't pay the
bill so i was just like why didn't you
pay and it's just like the idea of like
number one even when i look at like you
were just talking about old podcast of
yourself or old things of myself where
i'm like interrupting too much or like i
just don't i was like uh the idea of
seeing it in a child and just being like
no like uh
like i would shaming them for the thing
that you hate most you're holding up a
mirror to me it's a little mirror of a
little you that is supposed to be better
and better but i had resolved that and
i just modeled it or you inherited it
and now i have to live with the guilt
that it's like not just me hurting
myself it's like i brought you into this
mess and i think you're hitting on
something like i never have seen my mom
really like like herself in a way that
felt genuine or not like just like
saying it
i've never really seen it and that's not
my mom's amazing she's beautiful she's
so much funnier than me she's just like
the coolest and i know that but i've
never seen her know it so i never really
trust when she likes me too because i'm
like how could you you don't like your
you know you're the coolest and you
don't like you my friend recently lost
her mom to like trump
world you know where she's just like i
don't recognize my mom anymore i don't
know what happened over the past four or
five years like whatever years yeah
she's gone the one and it's every time
we talk we get in fights about these
things all the time and then she
eventually said mom i can't
i can't be in your life anymore more and
her mom goes okay then then i disagree
with him and she and she was like oh my
god my mom renounced all of this
bullshit and she's changed then it came
out her mom was just saying that because
she wanted to save a relationship with a
child and my friend realized that's all
i wanted i just wanted to know that you
loved me enough that you would do that
you don't need to and now it's
completely resolved her mom can like
trump and she can yeah and she's it she
always thought it was about trump and it
was about
she just wanted to know her mom loved
her more than something that her mom
seemed so passionate about she was maybe
jealous of that passion of like i don't
feel like you have that for me and then
she realized her mom did because her mom
renounced it and she just felt like this
person in her 40s oh my god this week
we are the only species that does this
dude most species they're born and they
just walk off they just walk they're
gone
and that was it done deal eat the
placenta really worry
i mean just see this i mean it took me a
long time to realize like you know it
and my therapist said this to me once of
like like parenting is a one-way
relationship you know like we do not we
it's a waterfall we do not take care of
the needs of our parent ever and like
and that is it but also i do think it's
a waterfall i do think it's on us to
kind of just be like when is it going to
be enough like when is this an
insatiable need i'm like my dad didn't
love me and he was never there and i'm
like he fucking came to the basketball
games he did this he i got a card like
what did i do you know when it's enough
i wanted to what fuck him like what did
i want i know i know and this is what
we're trying to heal but i whitney i
want to know and and for you as well i'm
like do you ever feel i have the
realization of the day if i ever
i don't mean to tread into weird
territory but if i when my parents are
gone and that's why i don't know why i
wanted to do the show i wanted to have
them on camera when they're like so
funny and still like
not demented and like with it and i
wanted like a little like time capsule
of it because it's going i can i know
it's going soon and they're so funny
still maybe because they're slipping
into it but um see for yourself may 1st
on e but um
nikki glazer question mark
you think it's reality it's actually
documentary on parkinson's so
what i feel like i had the realization
the other day is like the reason i want
to be
like to have achievements is so i can go
mom dad look what i'm doing and like
tell them about it and have them get
excited and have them watch and text me
like you were so good and when they go
when they're gone
i don't i don't know that there's anyone
else i want to show things off to like i
do it for them and i'm i even had a
thing with like the guy i'm dating i was
like i need you to watch me when i'm on
like
like daily pop on e and just like still
be like you looked you did good like i
need you to like watch things i'm on
because he's just like i like you i
don't need to watch
but then when he does it are you like
hanging my little like a plus paper on
the refrigerator are you able to say
like oh you're only doing that because i
told you to do it
i it's like that i want you to want to
wash the dishes well i know that when he
does watch things and he gives me
feedback it always feels really sincere
it's just a matter of him watching it
like i just need him to watch it because
once he watches something he's like damn
that was good and i it it's just a
matter of like i need to get him to
watch it you know what i'm saying so but
it it makes me i there was a moment of
like i don't even know that i'll want to
do this anymore if my parents are gone
because my dad died i was like oh my
whole engine was trying to get his
attention and impress him what happened
after i was like oh i was like floating
through space for a while um and i still
kind of i mean i i never
like i think shift for you in terms of
like i had like five projects set up
like tv shows i was just like can't do
them like pulled out of everything i was
like literally i just went to a wolf
sanctuary for a couple days and was like
sleeping with wolves
like i was just like finally a year late
because i like couldn't cry and then i
would cry
and like unconsolably like um
yeah yeah i was sleeping outside like it
was just like i couldn't
like deal with the pain it was just like
too much and it it was like not said and
on and it was like really sudden and i
think that nobody prepares like the only
thing we all know is gonna happen to us
but you're never prepared because no
like there's no wisdom you can get i
remember the day that it happened um uh
everyone that had lost a dad called me
it happens right away there's like a
network that's what i hear there's like
it happens right away i hear this kevin
christie and doon rayfield and lizzy
kaplan and you just get the call from
all of them and they know exactly what
to say
it's like a secret society it's just
like you don't want to hear from anyone
that has not lost their dad or the mom
situated the mom because they know
exactly what to say i cannot help you
here's what i can say do not talk to
anyone that has live parents for a while
you will hate them and you realize after
you've lost a parent how much other
people complain about their parents
every conversation is like oh my god my
dad's calling
you're like does your dad call like
little things get someone to take out of
your calendar father's day because
that's going to fucking sneak up on you
shit where it's like change all your
passwords if it's your day honestly i
look at losing a parent like lsd like
your life you will you can't go back
when you you'll see things like because
people describe that as like losing a
parent there's before losing a parent
and after it's the biggest challenge
when you become an adult like to me it's
when you come become an adult when you
are paying someone money
to put your parent in a box
and they're up charging you and you're
like that's not what it's i mean like
that's when you become an adult when
you're talking about like okay the body
has three days before it needs to be
produced like it you know
whenever i have this kind of like what
do you say to someone if you are someone
with a live parent and they lose their
parents is there any dude what do you do
it depends so number one you don't say
what can i do for you if you live in
their city you just show up at their
house with food jewish people figured it
out dude jewish people i literally after
a couple of my friends lost or went
through deaths and i saw jewish people
run a funeral and run death i was like i
want to convert to judaism because they
have death on fucking lock dude people
come every day with food
there's a plan all you're doing is
wishing there was a plan in place
because it's when you realize like oh
and look we are designed for this sheryl
sandberg and some guy wrote i'm not a
big lean in fan but her husband died
like really suddenly on a treadmill like
at the four seasons that's right and she
wrote a book on grief and like we are
designed for this you know something i
can't explain it but like something
happens
when you with that
i'm so that was a late lean in joke oh
wait which which by the way oh my god i
can't believe i was like thinking trying
to think of a joke i was like i haven't
said a joke in a while and i decided to
make one about her husband falling off a
treadmill and i said it's called her
book is called fall off
with the grief but we're designed for
this i can't explain it when your a
parent crosses something does happen
where you're like i'm the
adult now like i'm the leader of the
tribe now i'm the alpha now and like i
have to handle this you know and it's
like you're able to do things that you
never thought possible and with animal
deaths i'm really good at so whenever a
friend of mine has an animal dye like
i'm there emily came with me recently a
friend of ours um uh lost a dog he was
out of town like i'm the person that
comes in and is like
you just remember them how how they were
let me take the body i'll handle it from
here because at the end of the day
you're trying to reality your fur baby
whatever is it's just a bag in a parking
lot and you're they're trying to run
your credit card and it's not going
through oh my god you know what i mean
and they're saying like give me the po
box to ship the ashes like it's so
there's no dignity in death it goes from
my soulmate to like the bones didn't
really fit in the back like it turns
into like just were a
trash bag full of blood oh my god it
gets so gross so fast when you're
looking at a bill of like
people that i still like friends that
have lost parents and because i don't
relate to them and i know that i don't
relate and there's nothing i can say i
say nothing and there's i mean i can
think of people that i'm like avoiding
now because i dropped the ball so hard
and not reaching out because i was just
it was too overwhelming for me and like
what do you do what do you do they're
fine and and the cheryl sandberg book
they talk she talks about it of like as
soon as her husband died she went into
work and nobody would talk to her she
was like no one knew what to do the
irony is that like when but nobody
should either do you know what i'm
saying it's like it's no one can say the
right thing
there's nothing to say it's always just
show up so if there's a hot if someone's
sick in the hospital you do not say when
can i come you just show up you wait in
the waiting room for three hours if they
come great you say i'm in the waiting
room come if you want to talk if you
don't don't i came with food just just
solve a problem don't ask them how to
solve their problem because they they're
like you're like what can i do bring my
dad back to life
like there's nothing you can do
what can i do un-kill my mom so just be
there you're just literally just silent
and you show up without needing anything
without making it about you it was
really hard for me to understand that
before i lost a parent because i was the
person that was like let me be the best
friend and let me like show up here and
let me like ask you all the things i can
do for you like you just lost a uh did
you just furrow your brother and go like
that like what do you look like honestly
when you say show up i'm not trying to
play you just yeah
and you just go like i can't help you
what do you want me to do do you want to
watch a movie here for you do you want a
journal do you want to facetime someone
do you want to talk about it do you want
to not a big thing is do you want to not
talk about it do you want to talk about
something else do you want to like
gossip about me this is actually really
helpful because i i really
i'll go this i'll go here are my options
do you want to sit in silence do you
want uh to talk about something else do
you want to gossip about how like you
know that bitch we went to high school
with like cheated on her husband like do
you want to talk about the great good do
you want a drink do you like what do you
want and then i'll stay out of your way
so it's like i just you know we've lost
a lot of people in the last you know a
couple of years and it's like reaching
out to the wife of the widow it's like
i'm outside whether you need someone to
watch your animals i a lot of times will
just show up and be like let me know if
you need me to take your animals okay
like you know and then i'll have like a
canary for two months and i'm like jesus
christ and then um you know just because
that's the other thing is that when
someone dies the animals are the first
thing that is all of a sudden
overwhelming and the dog gets out and
the dog's lost and in addition that you
know what i mean just like little things
like that that's really helpful yeah
people think about this stuff bring food
over just bring food stock everything
with food bring water like do the
laundry like sometimes just show up like
a friend of mine lost a parent and i
just went to his house and just like
cleaned his house oh my god it's like a
little thing that like he could not have
done himself like i am being of service
in a way that is like not making it
about me or you know that's really like
that actually helps me because i
you know it's gonna start happening more
and more in my life that my friends are
gonna lose parents my i'm gonna lose
friends and like what do you do and i i
tend to just avoid because i know
there's nothing i can do so i'll just
stay away
and that just doesn't feel like the
answer so laundry i'll do laundry
literally laundry like cleaning stuff
like stuff that is like just put
yourself in a situation of someone that
just lost a parent like and now i have
to clean the shit off my toilet like
just sort of like the little things that
make a big difference like when you're
grieving like the tiny like you need to
be able to collapse and cry on
everything
at any moment
be it a toilet be in a shower so it's
like i just try to like go through
people's houses and i'm like okay you
can cry on this or you can cry on this
and you just i just you're such a helper
you're so good water by the bed what do
you need that's
me something else that's going to die oh
my god don't give me flowers don't give
me like i remember when my mom is in the
hospital the stroke the number of
balloons i was like you guys she i can't
see mine and then you just see it
sagging
totally i was just like
so i think it's just like the little
things that make a big difference when
you're just like crying a lot and you're
like there's a water there because
someone just thought to put it there but
i also think to make sure like you're
not trying to take any credit for it
it's just like i'm gonna provide this
for you and like we never have to speak
of it again
like don't do anything if you don't
think you're going to be able to like
know how to do it because by the way
everyone's got their in case of
emergency people and like i have to live
with the fact that i'm not everyone's
yes and if someone's going through
something like if you posted about
something like horrible that happened in
your life i'd be like hey i'm on my way
and it's like i'm probably not your top
five
and that's okay but i am now you would
be i'd be like hey i've got a load uh in
this
that's where i shine the washer that i
need to switch over to shine in crisis
like if you need i should show you what
you actually would be in my top five and
it's like that's and that's yeah that's
i i learn a lot from you in that way of
like the way that you've treated me and
and been there at the dr like anytime
anything's going on hey i'm sensing
something do you need to talk like i run
away from that because i just feel like
uh but you run into it i you i i don't
always like if it's someone that is like
a drama machine or someone that is like
sick or like i won't like i'm very like
okay before you solve a problem make
sure it's your problem if it's like
literally like a
life or death situation where i'm like
okay i'm uniquely qualified to be
someone that is like fearless and great
with like
really uncomfortable situations like
i'll go in or like dangerous animals or
like i'll just do it no like if you need
someone to like
be cool at your baby shower i'm not your
father okay
i'm the person recording like is baby
funeral isn't it i am your guy dude man
yeah like the yeah the the i'm the one
of the baby shout outs like isn't
circumcision kind of abuse like
for everyone oh my god
speaking of the i know we need to go but
like i really did you were talking about
the horse carriage thing you'll be the
one when i was in cabo i was in a bad
state of mind and i there was this like
dolphin enclosure where they like that
sea world s type thing and there was
this guy i was getting money of atm and
he was walking up to this kiosk where
they were selling all these adventures
and there's whale watching that's humane
enough but it seems like they're kind of
harassing the whales when we went out
and then you see the whales and you see
all of like the boat marks on their back
yeah and you're like they're like wow
they're really going today and they go
they're trying to get away from us we're
treating them like britney spears in
2008 like paparazzi like on their tail
and like
it so this guy was like uh my kids uh we
want to swim with dolphins and i just
i'm like
oh like i got i got to do it i gotta
stand up for the dolph i have to and i i
was just sitting there i just go
and the girl's showing him a brochure
and i go
they're abused and they like they
shouldn't be in that like you're
supporting like dolphins deserve to you
there's other things you can do that
isn't gonna harm them and he's just like
what and i go
there's other things you can do that
your kids are going to love and they'll
get to like be in nature and they won't
be like abusing animals like i know you
don't know but those animals are like
they're miserable and they're depressed
and they're slaves and he was just like
i want to see the dolphins
and like just sticks and he just hated
me so much and so he went and swam with
those dolphins even harder like i just
but i couldn't
not say it yeah
i had a feeling though that maybe he
went back to his kids and was like that
crazy lady said dolphins are abused and
maybe starter was like wait what okay
now i'm feeling like my brain is
clearing up after the right before the
podcast i heard something crazy and so i
was like a little slow and distracted to
close two hatches number one the thing
with the um
uh the course carriages i didn't finish
that what happened was the family
constellation she basically said like
two grandfathers ago i was like uh what
did he do that was so unforgivable he
probably just had like cirrhosis and it
would beat her or cheated on or whatever
and then i asked my uncle i was like
what's up with the
great-great-grandfather like what did he
like oh alcoholics throw something like
yeah of course yeah that makes sense
like whatever and then um he was like
yeah he um
actually invented this um contraption
that kept horse carriages from falling
apart so like they would always kind of
like spread apart and he figured out how
to make it so that they didn't this is
true yes
this is true this is what you found out
about your great grandfather and he was
two great great great great okay great
so he was a terrible businessman it's no
secret on this podcast that uh my
grandfather passed on investing in
mcdonald's because he said no one would
ever spend a dollar on a hamburger and
uh
[Laughter]
so
uh but i have an aunt that has a giant
beanie baby collection so i feel like we
it's all clean in the water you've
turned things around yeah yeah
completely
and so uh uh so yeah so it was like i
think there is like an inherited guilt
of like having been a part of something
like that you know it's like it's just i
it is even hardcore animal lovers isn't
that crazy for you to find out
i mean it was kind of a relief that it
was like
family was part of the business was
horse carriages the thing that you like
it makes me feel less crazy and it makes
me feel like there's some kind of cosmic
plan that like okay i'm getting driven
like you were talking earlier about like
how we're just like not making conscious
choices i do think i'm driven by like a
guilt and a sort of like okay as we move
through this life feeling like
purposeless and like figuring out our
terror management you know strategy i'm
like if i can just like spend time
trying to undo that mess that my
ancestors made like that is an honorable
existence you know that's that that's an
honorable way to spend our time you know
all of our ancestors did disgusting shit
if we can just kind of like untangle
that knot a tiny bit it's like the least
we can do but also i don't have it's
epigenetic imprinting there's some some
stuff that we can forgive ourselves for
whether we're crazy or irrational or
intense or whatever that is just like
forces that are driving us that is just
about our species proliferating and
being you know it's like it trusts me i
know anxiety is real i understand but a
lot of anxiety i think is good people
get anxious all the time i'm like yeah
you these are super powers you know like
this is like intuition this is your body
telling you to get out of the situation
like i feel like we defuse a lot of our
superpowers so i'm a little bit of a in
a place where i'm like oh if you had
told if you had said to me 10 years ago
if you were like having a drink at a bar
and we're like what is up with you and
the horses i'm like i don't know i feel
like one of my ancestors probably like
did something awful to horses and i like
him living my life trying to like clean
up that mess we would sound like crazy
people yeah i'd go to my friend who lost
her dad the next day i go you don't
believe what when he said last night you
want to talk about it get your mind off
your dad she said that her you know i
would have brought it up as like a
little bit of story a lot of the shit
that we say that sounds insane is like
true that's how why i mean it's just
weird to think no i just wonder what in
my past made me scared of fat drunk men
on diving boards that's one of my
irrational fears i don't like when men
get like too ballsy on diving boards and
they're drunk and they like bounce once
and then they go back up that bounce and
then they bounce again i'm scared
they're gonna like i i used to like
panic as a child and like be in the club
after swim meets like all the drunk dads
trying to show off so like and i'd just
be like no and i didn't want to hear the
sounds i was so scared they're going to
hit their like thrack their head on the
board that's the only social gathering
i'm not afraid of that's really good oh
my god i'm talking about it makes me
like
really nervous i love people with
delusional confidence
oh my god
they're like this tiny little diving
board i'm 400 pounds and like i'm gonna
do a front flip and like get like gina
from the country club to be my side
chick like i love them
just a crazy person like that but i'm
just laughing okay i know i have to let
you go but it's just like because i feel
like my brain just started functioning
after being on like a like a trauma
response of like
um i got some news earlier that i have a
family member in the hospital and my
brain just like had power down yeah but
wait the thing about the dolphins the
dolphin in captivity it's also this is
the thing about going back to hecklers
like was that you remember when you said
like have you ever been a heckler like
you in that situation if someone in my
show
needs to say what they need to say as
much as you needed to say that dolphin
was abused or i need to say
like i am not getting in between you and
this thing
yes okay
we're hecklers in our own way i really
do relate to people that speak up and
are like i don't like that like i'm just
like what what you're right that's like
okay let me hear you because this was
that's a ballsy move you just made and
usually it's alcohol induced because
they have liquid courage which is not
actual courage you're just dumber i
think people are like
i gotta tell her like people genuinely
think like it's just wild to me because
i'm like you believe in what you're
saying as strongly as i believe and what
i'm saying about the dolphin or whatever
yeah and like how i'm never gonna get in
between you and that strident volition
yeah because we relate to it we have we
have those passionate things too that
that we don't understand how people
don't get and then like looping back to
like will smith you had 12 strides to
change your mind yeah it's like someone
that had goals like they're like not now
not away
hold on
next one like they had plenty of time to
think this through oh my god i know
being drunk or whatever but like this is
i don't know it's like i just think it
is as i move through life and i am you
know when you look at someone else's
phone or computer and you're like how do
you live this way yes you look at the
apps on someone's home screen and you're
like whoa oh no i don't know that
feeling but i know people having that
response to my phone or they look at
yours like how do you live this way like
it is just i am constantly stunned that
people don't live the same way i do and
somehow something someone told me in
program in the very beginning they're
like the only thing worse than being
unconscious and not having a program is
having one and then living in a world
where most people don't have one right
and you feel like everybody's just like
a zombie being like pulled by marionette
dolls of like invisible forces of their
ego and alcoholism and dinner and you're
just like why doesn't everyone see
everything the way i do it almost sucks
to like have the veil lifted and see it
because you want to save everyone and
you want to like get people to
understand like okay well you do that
because of this and then you don't have
to do that anymore and and it just and
you oh you cut yourself off from a lot
of people and then you have to learn
further in program or whatever program
you're in like
that's part of it too is letting go of
trying to control people it's like never
when you see someone with a crazy eating
disorder i'm like
enjoy it while you can i say that to
people who drink i always go and they're
like i drink i hope you're enjoying it
you love it because there's gonna be a
day
you can't do it no more when you will
have had drank or will you when you had
an eating disorder you will have had it
so just enjoy it now where you don't
know you have it
like i just i don't want to take this
away from you this delusion that is the
way to overcome addiction i think is
acceptance that you need it this is a
thing like i had so much shame about
smoking pot i quit in
last last time you were on you were
talking about that yeah and what how
what helped me was to just i finally
stopped being like you god you're
smoking pot again it's the morning like
you said you weren't gonna do it and
just feeling shame and like oh like oh
god you you look the same as the guy on
hollywood boulevard like you're using
the same pipe as someone uses for meth
like this disgusting you want to be
loved like i used to have all those
thoughts this day i just go how about
you just are like
you know what girl you're doing your
best and this is a better thing than
binging this is a better thing like
thank god you have this pot you need
this because you're struggling today and
you're in pain good thing you have this
enjoy it because it's not to be around
forever the second i just like was like
yeah it fell away within a week it's by
the way once
and this is my whole thing about like i
think a lot of why we have to do things
is because they're taboo and do we make
them untaboo in order to like defuse
their power it's you know it's like when
i'm like you have to stop doing this bad
thing if i'm this isn't that bad then
all of a sudden that magnetic attraction
of like hurting myself goes away because
it stops being a weapon when you
unweaponize something that's when you
stop like
yourself with it the anxiety you have
from feeling shame about doing the thing
that is going to cause you to do that
more because the only way to soothe
anxiety about shame is to do so is to do
the so it's going to cause you to use
more just if you are drinking right now
and you're embarrassed of it and you
know you need to quit someday or you you
smoke pot too much or you have an eating
disorder if you do anything that you're
just embarrassed of try this week just
for me to just go thank god i have this
because the alternative is kicking my
dog
yeah if you didn't have that you need
that right now yeah thank god you have
it and fucking enjoy it because you are
going to get to a point where it's going
to go away so enjoy it now just
appreciate that you can get loaded
appreciate that you can you know scream
or do whatever you're doing just let
yourself off the hook for it don't be
ashamed about it because that's it's not
going to make it go away and it's going
to be over when it's over it's like they
say like
you know you're done fucking the gorilla
when the girl is done fucking you
they say that yeah
okay wait this is
what meetings are you going to
well i mean it's a one-on-one meeting
with this guy in his hotel room where
he's like no you're done when yeah
i'm done
is that not it
um no this is something that i heard a
lot in rehab of like it's a meeting
called the beast which is like it's
reality
okay it's called the beast
besides my animal rescue organization i
rescue them by fucking them yeah and uh
no it's a it's the beast and about sort
of like being humble to being able to go
like our ego says like i can handle this
today or i'm gonna stop eating those ten
sleeves of oreos if you're just like i
have absolutely no control over what i'm
going to do in 20 minutes
and i now know that about myself and the
more i go don't eat that the more likely
it is that i'm going to act out and cut
and hurt myself so just the idea of like
this is i have a beast on my back and
the more i fight this the harder it's
going to be for me so i can do the next
indicated action and just like sit on
the couch and like make an outreach call
or like write a gratitude list and just
hope that i don't piss this just don't
piss this thing off or when you do
go into it
just
forgive yourself for it and know that
you're not a bad person because you're
doing it like you don't want to be no
one wants to be an addict like you
didn't choose this and you might feel
like you're choosing but it's all you
have and it's also a superpower of like
i think also when you turn your like
character defects into superpowers it
really helps going like okay i'm eating
19 fig
fig newtons in a row
2 000 years ago i would be
the
most important person in the drive
like this i my brain is wired like this
for a reason
you know like these are superpowers i
don't need them anymore and then the
inner child work is what really helped
me but um in scarcity complex stuff but
just the idea of like
you're not you're you're this is like
we're wired to do this we're wired to go
like okay sugar can't eat as much as
possible and whatever and like then i'm
able to kind of like forgive myself and
dismantle it all and just go like you
can stop at any time that really helped
me i did go metformin i went on which
has really helped me with my like sugar
stuff because i used to like have like
major sugars what is it sorry metformin
so i do think especially since your
parents uh you're worried about them
everything david sinclair says to do the
nad the nmn metformin it's like all just
like new anti-aging stuff and just like
how to like
i used to i didn't like sugar at all
during the day but like at two in the
morning i would just go hard on like
fake protein bars oh it's just like
like thousands of grams of sugar okay
what else are we gonna close the
thousands because i just want to make
sure there's a lot of hatches open i
mean we did yeah i feel pretty good i
haven't been bored in this conversation
and
i don't know i i i think uh you know
we've probably lost a couple people in
certain places and that's you know
but they'll be i would like those people
to try to have
a
captivating conversation for two and a
half hours but here's what nobody here
but i also think it's like to me the
podcast i listen to it's like i'm not
like i don't want it to be like
interesting fact joke joe like i'm
hanging out with them and i'm learning
that but it's just i think that what i
i'm like learning today and i'm so glad
it's you is like when like life happens
and you're not feeling like funny or
like
interesting or whatever um
you still have to go to work i know and
this is one of those days i have these
days all the time i'm sorry that you
feel it with me but like i'm so glad
it's with you because i think if it was
any with anyone else i would just be
because like when i get sad like i had a
personal thing happen this morning and
when i get sad i just get like really
serious inside i would hope but yeah
like i was trying so hard to not be sad
today
and it's so tiring yes to like when you
just need to cry and you just can't
and then
i guess i just had such a like like the
inability to just sort of like feel your
feelings i haven't had that in a really
long time where it's like i had to be on
this tv show today where i had to like
be on and funny and silly and i just was
like
mad at the people making the show
that i'm like why are you making you
were dying like it just i was in such an
existential crisis and i just was like i
was trying to like show off like cool
things about my house and be funny and
um and it's just like we're dying and
but like it just nothing matters you
couldn't actually say what you wanted to
talk about yes and i feel so like
emotionally like constipated like dude
confused so i'm like so i feel like i
was very boring in the beginning because
i was just like
i was just like coming out of the haze
and i was the same way about myself and
i have so much guilt about it a lot of
times when i do podcasts where i'm just
like
did you say anything funny that's why i
made that stupid lean in like i was just
i loved it
i'm just like burping up this punch line
just trying to be interesting and that's
that's what i have the most guilt about
is like sometimes i'm like am i even
funny like you're too serious like i was
on doing the press today and people just
kept going like well this is a this is a
heavy show and i'm like i get that note
so much from lighthearted shows they go
like we went there today and i go
actually that's a good thing you know
what fuck it but you know what else it
is it's this thing of like and i'm a
woman i need to be i have to be twice as
funny to get half of it it's just sort
of like
at this point if you fuck with me you
fuck with me
and that's that's all they're like i
can't control this and i just try to go
like i'm giving someone permission today
to not have to be on all the time and
not have to be like you know whatever
and like i can also cut the boring shit
out later if i want to like it's just
sort of like
at what point you dumb whore are you
just gonna stop no but here's doing that
this is important if people do make it
to this podcast which who knows oh no
they will but if they make it to the end
i think this is actually
so awesome because so many people have
to show up to work when they aren't
feeling it and to see whitney cummings
who you just
project a lot of like she always she's
always on she can always like rally it
seems like nothing affects her it's nice
to see that sometimes this shit gets to
you too and like you're still showing up
and and providing in the way that you
can and like you can make something of
it so i think this is important for
people to see i love you so much nikki
glazer don't ride elephants i end these
awkwardly and i gotta get these hoops
off because i can't feel my head
[Music]
bye
[Applause]